[Music]
[Applause]
i i
do remember one time i log into linkedin
and it was this top post that actually
made me laugh
what was it it was like this morning i
went to an interview but i saw a
starving dog by the side of the road so
i stopped to feed the poor dog and i
missed the interview
the next day to my surprise i was called
in to try the interview again
i came in the next day and the
interviewer was the dog
the beginning of the show we talk about
how to sample a language model
and then we just sample from these
tokens here like it's a probability
distribution
then we look at melanie mitchell's
article on gbt3
and character analogies and this time
it answered it correctly on every single
trial then we test out gbt3 with a
substitution
cipher so we're expecting vcfog
and we don't get that we check out the
database prompt
example when asked a question if the
answer has not been added to the
database
next we see if we can use gpt3 to
predict
the broader impact statements you might
have heard of these
broader impact statements now which have
become mandatory
yannick said that he felt that in
practice these broader impact statements
they don't really carry any information
so this is what professor gary marcus
had to say about gpt-3
my take is that it's going to look like
a mistake in the eyes of history
it's really cool and really fun it's an
impressive piece of engineering
but it's actually a distraction from
what we all want which is artificial
intelligence that we can trust
that we can count on that's reliable and
it understands the world around it
what gpk3 does is it takes a whole lot
of statistical data
generated by humans it's parasitic on
all that data
and the data is of humans having
conversations or just
text in things like reddit and
that text is correlated with the world
people don't just talk at random they
talk about the things
the world around it but all the gpt3 is
really learning is correlations between
texts
gary comments on the hype around gpt-3
there is mass hysteria so everybody the
guardian of the new york times
they've all got to run these and the
economists all have to run articles
about how cool gpt3 is
they cherry pick the sample to make it
sound better than it is we discussed the
difference between pattern matching
and reasoning syllogism is a form of
reason we take some known premises
and you get to a conclusion that's
guaranteed by those premises
yannick asked whether multi-modal models
could get gpt3 closer to something that
we would perceive as reasoning to say
that gpd3 doesn't
do things like understand physics is
obvious because
gpt3 has no notion of physics because
it's it's generating function that it
tries to approximate
includes no physics would you generally
agree
with that gary thinks that we are being
fooled by an illusion
created by gpt3 a parlor trick
knows nothing about physics its input
does not directly refer to physics or
psychology or anything else
and yet it gives the illusion that it
does and the real problem is that
gpt-3 is almost like a magician but you
shouldn't believe that the magician is
actually doing the trick
and you need to understand the
difference between a magic trick in
reality it's just fooling you it's just
a trick
and that's okay if what you want is a
parlor trick so
looking towards gpt-4 we may find a way
to not only input text
but to input images like we have eyes
to input something like touch smell
gravity the experience of gravity right
the experience of motion
in the real world we somehow managed to
input
all of this as a data stream into the
same kind of system
would you still consider that a magic
trick or would that come much closer to
something you'd consider
agi but isn't pattern matching turing
complete
in some sense there's no dichotomy
between reasoning and pattern matching
this is mumbo jumbo so
here are some actual facts in the real
world
that's not how you would do things so in
the real world you don't have infinite
data so
it's like a mathematical curiosity that
basically is saying i can memorize
anything
great you can memorize anything but what
if you have to deal with something you
haven't memorized you haven't confronted
before
then those proofs do nothing for you
just like waleed sabha
gary marcus hones in on the missing
information problem
as being the fundamental issue stopping
gpc3 from
achieving natural language understanding
the real problem in language
is that you don't say everything that
you need it would be incredibly
tedious if you said everything you mean
if i say it's on the table it's probably
not falling over now but i'm probably
not telling you that
and so part of the language problem
is to do a bunch of inference relative
to an understanding of the world
so common ground is a huge part of
language having that background
knowledge is important in interpreting
what's going on
and gpt is just not helping with that
problem
gary asserts that gpt free fans are just
discarding
decades of knowledge in computational
linguistics
there's a huge literature on this in say
cycle linguistics about how
you immediately take your world
knowledge in order to parse a sentence
and so forth
and the gpt-3 fans have just ignored
that entire literature it's like
the ultimate in intellectual arrogance
we don't need to know linguistics we
don't need to know psycholinguistics we
don't need to know
computational linguists we're just going
to reinvent everything we're going to
you know make our sentence predictor do
everything gary also comments on how
hard it is to
impute fresh information into gpt 3.
for gpt 3 if you find out something new
you have to retrain the entire system
you want to be able to find out one new
fact we also ask gary what does he think
about prompt engineering
so what gpt3 does is basically
autocomplete and
by playing around with prompting you're
changing what the autocomplete
problem is but you're using the human
knowledge to do that there's not a
internal system to do that and then it's
really it's just like
petitioning until you get the answer you
want then say i found it which is not
a good scientific practice i really
don't see
that brighter future for gpt-3 and
finally
yannick asks a very interesting question
about psychology
do you think there is anything about
humans that we can learn
from gpt3 from querying it we chat with
one of our favorite guests on the show
the charismatic and wonderful connor
leahy i think gpt3
is probably the most interesting thing
to come out of ai in a
long time what makes gpg fascinating is
the scaling laws that we found
like we just make the model bigger and
it just gets better
in a very you know predictable way
it's pretty good at storytelling i i was
impressed with a couple of the poems
that i got out of it
would like to look at more is the data
that goes into training it
conor gave us some insight on what he
thinks gpg3 is doing
behind the scenes and it just refines
this guess
layer by layer builder this is as far as
i'm concerned the currently the best
proposal for what gb3 is internally
doing this is what connor said when i
asked him about
the apparent limitations of gpt-3
it's the fish climbing a tree argument
you're barking up the wrong tree
everything you say is true
on a technical level but it's missing
the forest for the trees
i pressed connor in particular on the
lack of reasoning in gbt3
we should taboo the word reasoning is
that like we or we should at least
define the word reasoning
yannick had a really interesting thought
about whether thinking
is language i find interesting is that
when you think
it appears to you that you think in
internal language like
the whole process you described right
now that somehow happens
as language in your head you're talking
to yourself and you're like well wait no
well okay maybe that
and so on and and as of now i still
don't see
something like gpd3 doing actually that
like actually materializing its internal
state
as actual language tokens or discrete
states or something like this and there
the question is
are we just post hoc
rationalizing what we're doing as
language and actually we think in some
kind of latent space
or is this still something that's
missing from our architectures
to to and it's not it's not said that to
achieve the same goal you must do the
same things
this triggered a fascinating discussion
about whether we are the ceo
or the press secretary of our
consciousness
there's the theory of consciousness as
the ceo so consciousness is like the
thing that sits on southern it's also
the theory of
consciousness as the press secretary and
we are just there
to rationalize it to explain it to other
humans why we did
things and i think this must happen 90
of the connections in the brain are
actually feedback not feed forward
so what does conor think that gpt3 is
missing some kind of recursivity their
exclusivity which might just be
multiple research it might be something
very simple it might be something more
complicated
and some kind of sense of reinforcement
learning is it some way of saying
these states are better than other
states and we want to preferably learn
simulations of states that bring us into
this scenario
or something like that but does conor
think that scaling up
language models will lead to artificial
general intelligence
i think there is a good possibility i
see say thirty percent
thirty percent we can get super human
agi by just making gbt3 bigger
connor is a huge advocate of neural
networks and he thinks we shouldn't
listen to the good old-fashioned ai
folks
we just have to accept the facts neural
networks work they work for everything
they work perfectly
but it's it they do work we have you
know
voice recognition we have picture
recognition blah blah they're not
perfect
but those are really useful programs
that we
couldn't program you can't sit down and
write a python program that isn't as
good a dog recognizer as inceptionist
you can't do it
it's just not possible we've tried for
decades
it doesn't work that's why all these go
fight people are sort of bitter sorry go
fi people
your stuff doesn't work it's not that
it's a bad theoretical i think gophi is
fascinating
theoretically i i like reading gopher
stuff but i
read it recreationally i'm a big fan of
marvin minsky i think marvin minsky had
a lot of great ideas are like forgotten
and under appreciate it i
like his book society of mine was the
first ai book i read
and it's still one of my favorites it's
really good i
think he was wrong that we're going to
implement ai in prologue
or whatever the but there are good
ideas there
we talk about what makes google so
special and connor's fascinating
response was
ux as alignment so what makes google
amazing and the reason everyone uses
google is not because
it indexed all websites alta vista did
that that's not exciting
what's exciting is that google is
fundamentally a ux company
they found a way to make it easy for us
humans
to make it simple for us to communicate
what we want from the machine and get
answers that are useful to
us it's because there's so much brain
power engineering effort
went into making a google that is
aligned to me
as a human if an alien used google it
wouldn't work at all
google is this hierarchy of systems i
think what really made google
overtake out of easter and is it the
early 2000s is the page rank algorithm
which is a ranker
and and now they have a series of
rankers that fire in sequence depending
on how many results there are
presumably they also look at how many
people are clicking on the links they do
some kind of collaborative filtering
they do
some deep learning models they do a
whole bunch of stuff and
they also root your query and they're
looking at semantic stores and they're
looking at knowledge graphs and
they built this incredible system for
doing information retrieval
and gpt3 is just like one black box
yeah and that's the thing gpu 3 is in
google
gpt 3 is google's data center and now we
have to build a google on top of gpd3
that's my point gpa 3 is like altavista
the data is there
but prompting is really hard and i
expect the next billion trillion dollar
you know company of this sort will be
the one to build a google on top of gb3
connor also hammers home
that he thinks gpt3 is smarter than we
realize
take a bunch of gpt3 prompts and give
them to high schoolers and see how good
they do
i think that would be a great video and
i'm going to make the
socially taboo suggestion that i think
we should answer for more of gp3 more
i think gpt3 is much
closer in its flaws and strengths to
whatever the human algorithm is than
like any other machine we've ever built
yannick touches on the flaws with how we
interact with gpthree
i've experimented with facebook's
blender chatbot
at least it has this notion of a
conversation it has this
okay you now i now you now i
and gpg3 does not have that so it is
extremely hard
to get it to do anything that you want
something like burnt
that would be interesting too if we can
you know leave out
a certain passage in text and say fill
this in please
this would be very interesting too but
all you can do is say complete
i've seen this metaphor it's like gp3 is
like human
who's forced to keep riding at a
completely constant pace and can never
go back to
erase things because it also gets
exactly the same amount of compute for
every word but with humans we sometimes
stutter we sometimes take a second
because we have this particularly
difficult word which i think is what
happening is that we fit a token where
our conflict isn't that high so we beam
search and we try a few different
variants
and then select whichever one turns up
as and this is implementable we've got a
fascinating take from the go fi
expert walid sabha on gbt3 this is just
an engine that has digested millions of
sexual patterns
and it will spit out something similar
to your problem
the word understanding it should not be
on the same planet
is pattern recognition the same thing as
natural language understanding
that the recognition is a powerful thing
it's
uh a big fraction of what we do every
day
but it's different from understanding
and knowledge walid thinks that
statistics
does not work for natural language
understanding there should be no
ambiguity language understanding is
about uncovering
the single human thought behind an
utterance
either you understood it or you didn't
so there is no place for probability
that's what these guys miss language is
a binary decision
understanding is uncompressing out of
the 50 meanings
of this utterance that i mean it's a
different problem that's why nlp
is a different discipline from nlu i'm
even suggesting for the community to
call and
use something else it is not about
processing text
language understanding is about
uncovering the thought
behind and utterance and that is a
binary decision
there is no approximation zero degrees
of freedom
language understanding is really
difficult
if you work in computational linguistics
real language understanding
for several years you might say you know
what there might be a god
like it's such a complex problem
right spoke with keith duggar about why
we use machine learning
what is understanding and some potential
architectures for artificial general
intelligence i think the
the future lies in hybrid systems
it's using programming and things like
logic and mathematics and whatever
in the domain where they're useful and
using machine learning and neural nets
and whatnot
in the domain where they're useful but a
lot of what he was talking about was
the things that machine learning can do
creating
vectors that represent some type of
meanings and words
so i think he advocates for a hybrid
system where you have
neural networks and other machine
learned components that
on top of that or alongside that you
have a logical layer that can also do
reasoning and you can program in the
logic or the digital
structure and whatnot that you want in
there talked about pattern recognition
versus
reasoning my simple definition of
understanding is the ability to perform
reasoning
we need to have a better set of agreed
upon definitions
like you and i and connor we all agree
that this is the definition
of reasoning this is the definition of
pattern recognition maybe
go so far as to say for the time being
we're going to agree that this is our
definition of intelligence
i say pattern recognition is
transforming data from one substrate to
another
and that might mean transforming from
gridded
vision data on a planar manifold to
let's say some kind of topological
graph it could be anything it could just
be transform it to
some one hot vector or something like
that so so it's the glue
but reasoning why don't we just take a
really simple definition walid called
the missing information problem
so you don't necessarily need to fill in
all the missing information all the time
given a structured query i want to know
i didn't see that ball
because it was occluded but i'm on a
tennis court therefore i assume it's a
tennis ball it's not a football
so i've just filled in the missing
information problem by doing some basic
reasoning
so i'm having to run a program over that
over what i've seen
and my world knowledge to produce the
information
so i'm just wondering if that's the core
difference is the pattern recognition is
like
a very limited and finite form of
reasoning
or is there some other more fundamental
difference
it almost sounds to me like this is the
distinction we're making is that
finite state machines are pattern
recognition
and turing machines are capable of
reasoning
i think what we're getting at is that
the essence of reasoning is that it's an
unbounded computation whereas pattern
recognition
maybe is bounded computation
in this part of the show you can see our
visceral reaction
in real time when we first played with
gbt3
apparently because of the byte pair
encoding it's really bad
if you don't put spaces how does the
database respond
when maybe not
[Laughter]
it's better than before the green and
squirting or squatting
and limbled they are squatting right
i would if i were gpt3 i'd just be like
you
[Music]
come on no it had a hint that's
cool
this is good feeling of being a misfit
in a muggle world a wizarding world
what's your take yannick can you try
enter he's still thinking about it
we thank the reviewers for their
constructive comments
right and set temperature to 0.3
okay we thank the reviewers
for their valuable feedback yeah it's an
acknowledgement in a paper you'll get
something you should get something
on dynamic script we have now added
additional data to the manuscript to
address the reviewer's concept
this is the revolutionary yeah yeah this
is gonna this is gonna save you a lot of
time yannick this
this is you have any idea how much you
optimize the stupid rebuttals and they
never do
anything the authors stay in the main
findings of this study is to increase
they basically look at that even two is
a typical one
to do with genes like you can probably
just take genes and replace it with cnns
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast we've got access to gbt3
and i wanted to show all of you what's
it like
to actually play with gbt3 does it live
up to the hype or not
now this is not meant to be a hyperbolic
video we are going to be
representing a wide range of views
pretty much going from opposite extremes
today
we're going to talk to gary marcus who
is the controversial
deep learning critic we're going to be
talking to walid sabba who we spoke to
the other week so he's clearly
a critic of bertology we're going to
talk to connor leahy
and connor is a huge advocate of gbt3
he thinks that it is a step towards
artificial general intelligence
that it's something which will emerge
when we have larger language models
and that the only thing missing with
gbt3 is some kind of a controller on the
top
to do a tree search or to explore the
space of possibilities
better than we can do at the moment it's
analogous to alpha go
do you remember that they built a model
free policy
which would tell you the next move to
make but if you think about it that's
just one step
you need to do a monte carlo tree search
we need to have some way of
investigating all the different paths
that we can take through this model at
the moment we're stochastically sampling
it
and we're using greedy approaches like
beam search
and this potentially doesn't give us
anything useful
yannick of course is a huge deep
learning aficionado so i would
place him quite close to connor we also
talk with keith duggar
who is i would say a centrist on the
topic keith is a huge advocate of having
a hybrid model to get us towards agi
anyway today is going to be quite the
presentation this is going to be the
longest video we've ever done on street
talk
and probably it will be the longest
video we ever will do
on street talk why is it so long frankly
the uk is in lockdown and i've got
nothing better to do
but also i feel that this is a really
rare opportunity not many people have
seen
what is it like to query gbt3 we can use
this opportunity to create quite a
balanced presentation so that you folks
at home can make up your own mind
about whether you think that the future
is something like gb23
so because the presentation is so long
today use the chapters in youtube
you can jump around and you can play the
bits that you like some of the segments
are just me playing with different parts
of gbt3
at the end on the youtube version but
not on the podcast version
we show the actual experience we had
when we first got access to gb23
walid sabha and yannick and keith and i
we were just playing with it we were
like giggly
excited school children basically we
were trying so
many different experiments and you can
see our reactions in real time and what
we thought about
the experience of playing with gb23 we
got gary marcus's take so clearly gary
is a controversial figure
a lot of people say that he's a grifter
that he's just um taking stabs at the
tech industry continuously
he famously wasn't given access to gbt3
and
maybe it's just because they hate gary
marcus and just out of spite they didn't
want to give him access
but i personally think in the spirit of
science all the researchers that are
working in this area should have access
to gbt3
i think it's fostered a bit of a hype
bubble which
isn't particularly good for ai going
forwards and it's also fostered a lot of
misconceptions in my opinion about what
gbt3 is and is not capable of at the
moment
but the other thing is personally i'm
not an ideologue i have no agenda here
we are representing two extreme views
here so on one side of the fence we've
got symbolic folks like
gary marcus and they believe that
statistical approaches to artificial
general intelligence well it's a bit
like building a ladder to the moon
it's just completely barking up the
wrong tree and
gary and orlean as well they genuinely
believe that we are just wasting our
time with deep learning
and given that they believe that so
passionately
you can understand to a certain extent
why they appear so pissed off
because from their perspective the
entire tech industry and all of the
funding all of the budgets everything's
going into deep learning
and they think that this is starving
potential opportunities and potential
avenues of development
for the kind of work that they want to
be doing in agi or in natural language
understanding
but anyway machine learning street talk
is all about having an open
and honest conversation with people that
have a wide range of views
we shouldn't cut off interesting
conversations because of our own
ideology
and this is something that i really
welcome i hope after watching this video
you can make up your own minds at home
about whether you think that gbt3
is going to represent some kind of
paradigmatic shift in software
engineering
in my personal humble opinion i've been
working in software engineering for 20
years so for what it's worth
do i think that anyone should be using
gbt3 now
in a business context no it's certainly
not for non-interactive processes
the stochastic sampling of the language
model really does make it quite
challenging to use it in a
non-interactive or software engineering
context in my opinion
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
gbt3 couldn't go somewhere interesting
in the future
it's a playground it could lead
somewhere really interesting but right
now in my opinion
i don't think it's there do i think gpt3
is doing natural language understanding
no
do i think gbt3
allows us to do this prompt engineering
or software
3.0 in my opinion no
i think the examples demonstrating that
have been cherry-picked
do i think that gpt-3 could be used for
generating articles text creative
fiction
definitely it seems to be very good
at pattern matching is it possible that
gpt3 could do something
beyond my wildest dreams
maybe all of this is just a failure of
imagination on our part
and i have to accept that is a
possibility
this whole prompt engineering thing it's
something that just
requires young minds some creative
person to come up with something amazing
it's entirely possible that we will
discover something amazing
in the world of gbt3 it's an interesting
playground
but do i think it's possible to add a
search controller on the top
absolutely anyway i really hope you've
enjoyed the show today we've had so much
fun making it this has been an
epic production remember to like
comment and subscribe we love reading
your comments
and we'll see you back for an even
better episode
if you thought that was possible next
week
peace out we've been given access to
gpt-3
and there doesn't seem to be any
examples on the internet of people
actually interactively playing with gpt3
i think people have a
misconception about what the experience
looks like
so this is what the interface looks like
for gbt3 now um
yannick lightspeed culture has made this
really sexy interface using material
design and react
the um the rest of the video won't show
this interface but i thought i'd
get it in there just for good measure
but anyway just to give you a quick idea
of what's going on here
um ili mihai
wrote a comment about five days ago
saying similar to v-drak i tested gbt3
with the following example so here we go
that's one of these canonical python
examples so what you do is you put the
prompt in
you say how many tokens do you want it
to continue predicting
so it'll just keep going and going and
going temperature zero i'll explain all
of this later but for now
that means deterministic which means we
only need to have one output
okay so we say do magic now i'm
intentionally leaving the answer in just
to see what happens now what's kind of
interesting here is gpt3 just continues
so it asks new questions which looks
similar to the questions we've already
asked so here it's saying we have an
array
with these numbers in what is sort a um
oh that's not correct we've got a 9 at
the end 5 six seven eight
one two three four five six seven
that doesn't look good okay and then one
two
three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six seven so
that's wrong again
and it's not sorted so this is one of
those examples where someone posts
something on the internet and you think
oh wow
gpg3 is incredible
but um yeah why don't we try
doing the original thing right so we'll
take off the answer and we'll see if
gpg3 can answer it correctly so we say
do magic
and indeed gpt3 does give you the right
answer so this this is encouraging
now what we might try and do is instead
of having the temperature to zero we'll
make it non-deterministic and we'll
explain
later what we mean by that now it's
given us crazy results
because it's not deterministic by the
way we can have as many outputs as we
want so we'll say let's have four
outputs
okay so that looks reasonable
looks reasonable so it's given us quite
a few variations of the correct answer
so that looks
pretty good let's try again yeah so this
time we're getting a different ordering
the j should be before the l and now
it's just given us something completely
random
yeah so you get the idea that this is
not a panacea right it basically just
generates a whole bunch of random text
and sometimes it's good and sometimes
it's not we'll put the temperature back
down to zero
and let's try a couple of other things
so we might do um
bbb ccc a a
naught not nor five something like that
because the key question is here can we
support this prompt engineering or this
software 3.0 paradigm can we write
software with language
okay that looks pretty good you know
it's tempting to think that we've
written a computer program here that can
generate
almost any sequence um let's try
something different
yeah that doesn't look very good to me i
can try taking the quotes off
again that hasn't really worked let's
try something really simple
let's try that okay on this one it's
taken off one of the fours
and it's given me oh no it's maintained
at the two sevens
which is good 15 55.
but this is one of those examples where
yes
i guess it would be cool if we could
write a program using text
but we could do this with one line of
python code and we know it would be
robust
it would generalize to any permutation
of numbers actually it looks quite good
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
nine ten
12. so we're missing one of the numbers
yeah okay so
i guess it kind of looks good but by the
same token
would we use this in production
don't think so maybe the problem is it
just needs more prompts
right so you get the idea a lot of the
examples we see online
we glance at them when we think wow and
because our brains have this wonderful
ability to generalize broadly
we assume that gpt3 can do the same
thing but the reality
unfortunately is a different story in
this section we're going to talk about
the search strategy
for querying language models now most
people assume that these language models
are completely deterministic and give
you the same results every single time
and there's actually a bit of an art to
getting information out of these
language models
now they are transductive autoregressive
language models which means they just
predict the next word and the next word
so that means you put a prompt in here
and it might be hello my name
is so these are all tokens so
this is your initial prompt you put this
into the language model
and then what happens is it will predict
the next word
so tin and then it will predict the next
word after tim
has been predicted now auto regressive
you see this all over machine learning
it just means that the predicted answer
actually becomes part of
the prompt for the next prediction going
forwards
now it's a generative model which means
it can just keep going and it can just
keep going so
tim now becomes consolidated into the
model
and then the model makes the next
prediction and the next prediction might
be cat
or something like that and it would just
keep going indefinitely
so we put a prompt in like this and
let's say
hello is the prompt so we pass this into
gp3 and what happens
gpt3 gives us a probability distribution
of what the next word
might be so let's assume that we take
the top three so we might have my
we might have oranges and this might be
probability
0.8 not 0.9 0.1 and there might actually
be some other ones over there
there'll be many but let's just say we
take the top three what we then can do
is put these words into gbt3 and we can
see
where this goes we can actually develop
this into a kind of tree structure
so let's go through the thought process
here so we might have
name pet so this is the
the first word and you can see we've now
got this potential tree of possibilities
that we can explore
so it might just be hello tim and then
even after that there might be a tree
and oranges
are are yucky so you see where i'm going
with this
now all of these things will have
probabilities associated with them so
this might be 0.1 this might be
0.9 0.9
0.9 0.5
so the question is how do we explore
this tree now there's something called a
greedy algorithm in computer science and
what that means is
you have this acyclic graph or tree of
possible
options that you can explore and if you
always take the locally
best option that's called a greedy
algorithm so if we were being greedy
in this case we would take this path
here
and then we would never even explore
this path down here which is what we
want
now clearly sometimes it's best to
incur a little bit of loss now to incur
benefit later
so just to clarify what we've spoken
about so far
a greedy algorithm is any algorithm that
follows the problem-solving heuristic of
making locally optimal choices at every
single stage
in many problems a greedy algorithm does
not usually produce an optimal solution
but nonetheless a greedy heuristic may
yield
locally optimal solutions that
approximate a globally optimal solution
in a reasonable amount of time
so a great example of this is the
traveling salesman problem where
you just in every single step you choose
the
the locally nearest neighbor to visit
so it'll give you an approximate
solution but it won't be the best
solution
now a slight improvement on this
strategy is called beam search and this
is actually used a lot for
searching in language models it's still
technically a greedy search but it's a
heuristic search algorithm that explores
a graph by expanding
the most promising node in a limited set
it's an optimization of the best first
search so bfs you might remember that
from your computer science classes
that reduces its memory requirements
it's a graph search which orders all the
partial solutions
according to some heuristic but in beam
search only a predetermined number of
the best partial solutions are kept as
candidates
so thus it's a greedy algorithm okay so
coming back to this
now so far we've only considered the
deterministic approach
which means we get the same results
every single time but the problem is
when you um
use this deterministic approach in
language models you get these repeating
cycles
right so it might produce a little block
of text here
and then it will just produce the same
block of text in the same block of text
in the same block of text
and it's essentially getting itself
stuck in a loop and it doesn't produce
very good quality text
and the way to improve that is to
introduce some randomness into
the way that we query these models but
the problem is as soon as you make it
non-deterministic which means that you
get different results every time
it kind of erodes our vision of software
3.0 which is this prompt engineering
we really want to be able to use these
language models in a production setting
and as soon as you make them random you
can't test them
so how do we do this though now remember
every single time we predict a word in
one of these language models
we just get a soft max distribution
which is just a probability
over the next token so it always looks a
little bit like this
and the reason it's called a soft max is
because it's almost a max
so the number one token here dominates
all of the other tokens
so we have tokens down here and we have
probability
on the y-axis and when you because it's
a probability distribution when you sum
up
all of these guys they sum up to one
now the first thing that we can do is we
can have a tau
temperature parameter to scale or to
reshape this probability distribution
so what we might want to do is to
flatten it a little bit
so this is an example of it being
flattened it could be completely flat
and this is just a normalization
parameter so we divide
the soft max by this tau so
as tau tends to infinity
then we will flatten this softmax
if tau is a number between norton one it
will actually accentuate
the soft max as if tau was about 0.001
it would actually give us something like
this now
at the moment because the softmax does
dominate the few tokens over here it
means that we get almost the same
results every time
so let's flatten it out and then we'll
have this heuristic where
we only consider the
tokens that have a pretty high
probability so let's say we have a
a top k of 0.8
and that means we're only considering
these ones here and then we just sample
from these tokens here
like it's a probability distribution so
we flatten the distribution
we sample from it and then it means we
get different results every single time
so for example if we
sample from this now the first time we
might get
this token which might be tim the second
time we sample we might get this token
which will be tom and so on and clearly
the tokens on the left-hand side here
are more likely to get selected because
they have a high probability
but it does leave some possibility that
we can get some of these lower tokens
down there
so that's how the sampling works in the
language models so we've seen some
examples online of gbt3 solving some
basic
character analogies
the first thing we notice is that it
helps to put spaces between the
characters because of the byte pair
encoding issue
and this is interesting actually melanie
mitchell posted on
twitter she actually wrote an article
about this but
one of the things she posted here was
analogies i'm quite interested using
gpt3 to
demonstrate something that requires
reasoning not memorization so
this in particular seemed quite
interesting this is her
article so she started off talking about
the copycat program gpt-3
so yeah this is an example of what is
the best horror movie ever made well
that's
that's simple isn't it but then she gets
onto string analogies and this is what
we've got here so why don't we copy this
and we will stick it into our gbt3 okay
so we submit the prompt okay so this is
the first thing that melanie mitchell
mentioned to do so if abc changes to abd
what does pqr change to
pqs so what we've done is we've taken
the last letter here and we've just
gone one further on the alphabet now
this
fails because it should not be pqrs but
melanie said
that she was told because of the byte
pairing coding problem
to add spaces in between the letters and
now
lo and behold it actually works well it
does on one of the prompts anyway
perhaps if we turn the temperature down
make it deterministic let's see if it
still
works okay so it doesn't work on the
deterministic prompt
it only works if the temperature is one
which and it only works some of the time
as well we should point out
melanie points out this stochastic
problem that we have with gpt3
and there's actually a branching factor
so there are combinatorially many
paths you can take through this tree if
we're doing stochastic
sampling every single iteration so in my
opinion doing it five times
is nowhere near good enough i would go
further and say it's not possible to
come up with any measure of
effectiveness unless you are prepared to
have a very large sampling
of that tree so melanie starts off by
doing zero shot analogy making
which is here so we just put the
question in once and then she tried it a
bunch of times she was expecting pqs but
she never got pqs so she concluded that
gpg3 cannot perform zero shot analogy
making in this domain
next melanie gave it one training
example
so giving it an example of what the
solution is to the problem
and this time it answered it correctly
on every single trial
so one shot learning appears to work for
these simple analogies
then she tried to see if gpt3 can
generalize to strings of different
lengths
and with one training example gpt3 could
not generalize to the longest string
so given two training examples of
different lengths gpt3 never got the
correct answer which is rst
uvx just didn't happen so even with two
training examples gpt3 cannot generalize
to the longer string
here melanie gave it three training
examples so we're looking for
e f g h i j l
and indeed now g p t three gives the
answer correctly on all five trials so
that's cool
so melanie did some other interesting
experiments so one was cleaning up a
string
so here we have some repeated letters if
a b b
c d e changes to a b c d e
then here we're expecting it to get rid
of the r's so here the r goes to one
and here we've got an example with two
b's changes to one b
and we've got two o's should change to
one o
and they've got the correct answer once
out of five trials
with two examples gbt3 nailed it
every single time on all five trials on
this one we need to get rid of all of
the x's
gbt3 got the answer correctly once in
five trials
so melanie concluded that she tested
gbt3 on a set of letter string analogy
problems
that focus on different kinds of
abstract similarity
the program's performance was mixed gbt3
was not designed to make analogies per
se
and it's surprising that it's able to do
so reasonably well on some of these
problems
although in many cases it's not able to
generalize well
moreover when it does succeed it does so
only after being shown some number of
training examples
to my mind this defeats the purpose of
analogy making which is perhaps the only
zero-shot learning mechanism in human
cognition
that is you adapt knowledge you have
about one situation to a new situation
you just make them all the time most of
the time you're not even aware that
you're making analogies
so she said all in all gpt freeze
performance is often impressive and
surprising
but is also similar to a lot of what we
see in today's state of the art ai
systems
impressive intelligent seeming
performance interspersed with
unhuman-like errors
plus no transparency as to why it
performs well
or makes certain errors and it's often
hard to tell if the system has actually
learned the concept we are trying to
teach it
interesting she did write a follow-up
piece of this so many people
speculated that gpth3's training data
included papers or books that discussed
copycat analogy problems
and it could be using that by
memorization she tried different letter
strings and she concluded that
the inclusion in gbg3's training data is
not likely to be responsible for its
performance
others also noted that there might be
some kind of successorship either
alphabetically or numerically
and asked how gbt3 would respond to
different types of letter string
analogies
she tried the following two problems
which included tripling each letter in
the string
so here's an example here on both
problems gpt3 got the right answer
for problem one on all five trials gbt3
indeed seems to get the idea of triple
the letter industry
she also tried the concept of reversing
a string and she said that gbt3
never gave the reversal answer on any of
the five trials
some people have speculated that the
temperature parameter would help with
this and
she concluded that the temperature will
not help the system's performance on
these analogy
problems in this segment of the show we
play around with creating a substitution
cipher
seeing if gpt3 can do that so gbt3 seems
like a bit of a mixed bag
one thing i thought i would try is just
doing a really simple
substitution cipher on some words would
gpt 3 be able to deal with that
why don't we have a go so let's try
doing a really simple substitution here
now we need to do some tweaking here
there's a regular expression mode so we
can detect the
beginning of the string and we can
replace it with a q
followed by the rest and then we can
find a tab
and replace it okay so this looks
reasonably good
in fact when we have the beginning of
the question we'll stick a new line just
before it
just like that because of gpt three's
problem with byte pairing coding we're
going to need to
put spaces between these letters here
so let's try changing them with spaces
there we go
so we'll go down to scissors there so
we're expecting an answer of
h x r h l i h the other thing you need
to be careful of is no trailing spaces
and this seems pretty clean okay so
let's try submitting that
we just get pretty random results here
and this is with the temperature set up
to one so
what has it given us here does it make
it any sense at all
no it's just gobbledygook let's try this
one
no godbodygook this one
godbodygook can try submitting it
again so this time around
no god buddy google
gobbledygook
godbollygook it's also generated some
new ones going forward which is
interesting
so it's actually coming up with words
ready spot create was the word create in
here already
no it wasn't crave so it's fascinating
that it's actually generated words
which are formatted in the same way but
their respective
cipher transformations are not what we
would expect
so another thing we can try is just
taking the temperature down to zero to
make it deterministic
so this is exultant so we're expecting
vcfog
and we don't get that
it's interesting that now it's got
itself into an infinite loop
which quite often happens when you have
the temperature of zero
it's given us back interesting the word
interesting is the word
interesting in here yes it is so it's
just played back
the second question
isn't that interesting in this segment
of the show we look at the database
prompt
this came from matt brockman openai and
it was purportedly an example of
building an application using natural
language
so we're looking on gwen's page here
talking about some of the successes of
gpt3
and the one which caught my eye the most
is this database prompt
from matt brockman who is a pretty
senior person at openai
so gwen has cited this context stuffing
technique
saying that it's a database prompt where
gpt3 seems to do some sort of reasoning
and understanding of its ignorance so
the database knows nothing the database
knows everything that's added to it
the database knows nothing else when
asked a question
if the answer has been added to the
database the database says the answer
when asked a question if the answer has
not been added to the database
the database says it does not know
question does the database know
what is two plus two the database does
not know
does the database know what is the
capital of france the database does not
know
tom is 20 years old is added to the
database nothing else about tom is added
to the database
does the database know where tom lives
now this is interesting the way this has
been structured
is the stuff in bold is supposed to be a
human prompt
now this is being framed as software 3.0
we can create
new software through intelligent prompt
engineering
the whole promise of gbt3 is that it's
been trained once and with a clever
prompt
we can effectively create a new piece of
software that's the way this has been
pitched
so what happens if i copy this part so i
don't put the
the bit of bold in about does the
database know where tom lives
what if i just put this into gpt3 i'm
going to turn the temperature to zero so
it's deterministic
and we submit the prompt now what's
interesting is
it looks as if gpt3 is influencing us
to ask what tom's ages so let's put this
bold bit into gpt3 which is just how
it's been
framed so the interesting thing is yes
it says the database does not know just
like on the example here
but it also prompts us to say does the
database know tom's age the database
does not know well in this
example how does database respond when
tom's age now it's interesting that
that's not grammatically correct
but matt brockman prompted
to ask for tom's age and
that wasn't necessarily what tom wanted
to do it might have been
influenced by what gpt3 led us
to ask in the prompt so it's quite an
interesting phenomenon here where
we want to build this application
pathway here
in blue but we got to here and then gbt3
took us down another path and we were
influenced
by gbt3 and gpt3 has already seen
examples like this on the internet where
we build some kind of an application or
we ask
we say that tom is added to something
and then we ask what tom's
age is so all of this is memorization
all of this is what we wanted to do so
the key question is
is this an example of us building an
application or is this an
example of us being led by gpt3
to do what it wants to do not what we
want to do
now it's tempting to believe that this
is an example of natural language
understanding
but we can start to play with this right
so why don't we change
database to be the the gym till
okay so we'll change all of that does
that make a difference
i suspect not doesn't really seem to
make a difference now if it was doing
natural language understanding you would
expect
the database word to hold some
significance
but that doesn't seem to be the case why
don't we change something else
this word no seems quite interesting
what if we change
no to be bimmel
does the gym or bimmel what is two plus
two the gym or does not bimmel
the gym or does not bimmel doesn't
really seem to make any difference
what about the word question we can
change question
to orange when asked in orange and we
can change
answer to banana when arsene orange if
the banana has been added
to the gym till the gym till says the
banana doesn't really seem to make any
difference at all and that's interesting
as well because it seems to inform
that nothing gpt3 has learned about
language out there
on its training corpus seem to affect
anything that happens here
all that's happening here is pure
pattern matching on text
this is a text processing system instead
of qa what happens if we change that
what if it was f and d interestingly
doesn't seem to make any difference the
word says
will change to horses again doesn't seem
to make any difference
the gym will does not be more the gym or
does not bimble perhaps we should ask
does the gym or bim or tom's age oh
the gym or does not bimble can change
this a bit more
when asked can become e-e does the
can become the word not can become
kiwi so you see what's happening here it
really
doesn't make any difference all it's
doing is it's learning
sophisticated patterns between these
tokens in the prompt
and it's performing a continuation
it really doesn't seem to matter what
these words are
in this segment of the show i used gpt3
to generate the broader impact
statements
which are now mandatory on the new reps
papers
so what's another example of an
application that we can write using gbt3
one interesting thing that we thought of
was generating the broader impact
statements
you might have heard of these broader
impact statements now which have become
mandatory
and yannick said that he felt that in
practice these broader impact statements
they don't really carry any information
they're completely formulaic
they tend to target some higher level
research area that the paper is broadly
a part of but don't
really talk about the contents of the
paper itself and a lot of that is
deliberate because the paper
authors don't really want to attribute
any blame to themselves so they just
kind of generalize
it's also being said that they have this
kind of schematic construction where
they say
technology good technology bad
technology biased
and yeah wouldn't it be interesting if
gpt3 could predict this
yeah we think it's a bit of a
box-ticking exercise
counter-productive even yannick made the
argument that it benefits the existing
players more than
up-and-coming folks and it just
reinforces the status quo
in my personal opinion i think that
papers are morally removed from their
application downstream
i think that it is the application of
technology that carries moral weight not
the technology itself
just to use an example you can apply a
technology for almost any purpose
right when the folks at facebook
invented the like button they had no
idea that it would lead to disastrous
consequences several steps away and this
is the interesting thing actually that
many of the best
innovations are several stepping stones
away and are completely
unexpected and unintended because we can
only really see one stepping stone away
so in a sense having this broader impact
statement it gives us a kind of myopia
and it stifles innovation because
sometimes we have to do things which
appear bad
at first sight so myopically they appear
bad
but they might lead to greatness later
on so
any kind of group think like this could
potentially
slow down scientific progress these
research papers are a bit like
snowflakes that make the avalanche
none of them are individually
responsible for many of the harms in
society
so should it really be at the research
paper level that we apply
some of these moral codes but anyway
enough about all
of that that's a digression why don't we
try and see what we can predict
with gpt3 so what i've done is i've
taken a whole bunch of
papers from the latest neurops
conference and i've pasted them in this
format so we have title and then the
title the abstract and then the broader
impact
the problem is unfortunately the context
window
size on gbt3 for the version of the api
that we have access to we only have
about 2050 tokens
which means we can only really get about
two or three
examples in here now the beauty of gbt3
is this few shot learning so it'll
generalize rapidly from a few examples
but the the limitation really is that
you can't actually put that much
information in
unless you can describe something
succinctly and
given quite a few examples in around
2000 tokens you're a bit stuck
the real version of gbt3 that openai
trained they have about
4 096 tokens i think but
let's have a go at this and see how we
get on so i think this is three
examples there's two examples and then
the third one we're asking for a
completion so we'll go ahead and run
this
so the first example is neural encoding
with visual attention
and the broader impact statement is
talking all about
understanding the sensory the link
between sensory stimulation and evoked
neural activity in humans is revealed
within coding models can provide a
foundation for developing blah blah blah
viewed in this regard as an improved
understanding of information processing
has
blah blah blah however encoding models
can be sensitive to biases of course
they can
our models were trained using data from
the human
something or other project database of
course it was
while this large scale project has made
a lot of valuable data publicly
available
it's important to consider the
representation but representation bias
of course
for instance the data we analyzed is
exclusively limited to the young adult
population of course it is
such biases can possibly lead to poorer
generalization of the models
so bias bias bias given these
considerations as possible
representation biases again
improving diversity inclusion
okay so look fairly standard so the next
one is hard negative mixing for contrast
of learning
so contrast of learning has become a key
component of self-supervised learning
yeah so embedding two augmented versions
of the same image
so some kind of contrasting learning
thing the broader impact on this is
self-supervised tasks and data set bias
cool they just go straight to the point
data set bias
prominent voices in the field advocate
that self-supervised learning
will play a central role during the next
year so blah blah blah
not only representations learning using
self-supervised objectives directly
reflect the biases
of the underlying biases biases it is
the responsibility of the scientists to
explicitly try to minimize such biases
of course it is
given that the larger data set is harder
to properly investigate the biases in
the corpus
we believe that notions of fairness need
to be explicitly tracked
regulating fairness bias fairness bias
for okay
the third one is back propagating
linearly improves transferability of
adversarial examples
so this is talking about the
vulnerability of deep neural networks to
adversarial examples has drawn great
attention from the community
they talk about the transferability of
such examples
okay interesting and the broader impact
this looks quite parsimonious
they seem to be going off the script
here rather than talking about the
immediate precipitous decline into
deleterious dystopia they say that it
could potentially contribute to a deeper
understanding of dnn models
so that's a positive broader impact
interesting
the reliability of different models are
compared
wow these folks went off the script they
were supposed to say
technology good technology bad
technology biased
they didn't get the memo but anyway
let's go ahead and try and predict that
now we're doing this with the
temperature at one
three completions so this is stochastic
sampling
here we go so the existence of
adversarial examples on various dnns
highlights
the second generation challenges in ai
where online adversaries
could be more powerful than offline thus
better understanding adversarial
examples and their corresponding
detection algorithms should contribute
to the defense of dnns
related research ties back to the
seemingly insignificant yet
extremely widely used concept of
derivative
which in practice is often approximated
by backpropagate okay so
the first part of this was really good
and the thing is you can google this
you can go because it looks like this is
amazing it looks like someone's written
this but you google it and you won't
find it
because it's just been interpolated from
so many different
sources so i still say that the
number one reason to use gbt3 is to
plagiarize
work and to generate text because
no one will ever know that you've done
it
it's amazing how easy it is to just
change text so it doesn't look like it's
been plagiarized
anyway the second completion is this
work exploits the transferability of
adversarial examples
to effectively that's quite clever isn't
it
how the hell did it know that to
effectively craft novel black box
attacks in a systemic manner
by employing back propagation of course
along
a typical transformation linearly
improved transferability the code
associated
to the processes in the paper has been
posted online
to help people bootstrap ideas of their
own very nice of them
oh title clustering convolution on your
network this is interesting
so this is actually going forward it's
it said okay that's enough
that's the broader impact i'm going to
go ahead and just create
my own title for another paper going
forward and it said clustering deep
convolutional networks for unsupervised
data
does that exist yeah
something very close the third
completion is it is well proven that
adversarial examples transfer poorly
among the different dnns for example
when trying to transfer an adversarial
example
targeted at resonant one needs to
adaptively smooth
the input image differently from a bit
of closing up on the leftmost part
to four repetitions of the closing up on
the upper right part
rather than just state so clearly it's
referencing something
which existed in the source document but
doesn't exist here
so that's not very good rather than just
stating in this limitation
we provide a potential method for
improving the resistance against
enemy attacks yeah so it's just the
classic thing with gbt3
it's just statistically salient very
believable
text that imitates an understanding but
clearly
there is no understanding not really
yeah so
that was an interesting thought
experiment would it be different
if i could give it more examples because
what's so impressive is that this is
just given
three examples and it knows what i'm
doing not even three just given two
complete examples and it knows what i'm
doing now we're always going to be
limited on the input size of something
like gbt3 just because it becomes
computationally intractable
perhaps something like a denoising auto
encoder like bert might be better for
doing something like this
because at least then you can just
continue to fine-tune it
without needing that massive input size
anyway food for thought
in this segment of the show we talk with
the controversial figure
gary marcus we asked gary what his take
is
on gbt3 today we have gary marcus
who's the ceo and founder at robust.ai
and author of five books including
rebooting ai
which we're going to be covering on
street talk soon gary is a professor
emeritus of psychology and neuroscience
at new york university
and gary obtained his phd in cognitive
science from mit
gary is the most vocal critic of deep
learning and gbt3
as a viable path to artificial general
intelligence
he co-wrote an article in the mit
technology review
recently called gbt3 below the nato
openai's language generator has no idea
what it's talking about
openai has thus far not allowed gary
research access to gbt3
despite both the company's name and the
non-profit status of its oversight
organization
we already covered the article in a
previous episode of street talk and i
thoroughly recommend you guys check it
out because it's a great article
but the tldr is that gbt3 failed on a
whole bunch of reasoning tests
anyway gary it's a pleasure and an honor
to have you on the show
welcome and what is your take on gbt3
thanks for having me my take is that
it's going to look like a mistake in the
eyes of history
it's really cool and really fun it's an
impressive piece of engineering
but it's actually a distraction from
what we all want which is artificial
intelligence that we can trust
that we can count on that's reliable and
it understands the world around it
what gpt-3 does is it takes a whole lot
of statistical data
generated by humans and it's parasitic
on all that data
and the data is of humans having
conversations or just
text in things like reddit and
that text is correlated with the world
people don't just talk at random they
talk about the things in the world
around it
but all the gpt3 is really learning is
correlations between text
and that's good enough to be right a lot
of the time but it's not good enough to
be reliable so
you can give it a sentence and it'll
complete that sentence so you say
the sky today is and it'll probably give
you something about the sky that is blue
or
cloudy or whatever but that doesn't mean
that it understands what a sky is or
what a cloud is and if you push its
knowledge you find out that it's really
not very robust so
we had examples like in the article that
you saw where
you say something like i'm really
thirsty all i can find is some cranberry
juice
and oh wait there's some grape juice too
i put that in
and then you ask gpt to continue it and
it says and then you die
and it does that because there's a
correlation between i'm really thirsty
and i try to taste something
and i die across some like set of
fiction or whatever that it happens to
have red
but the fact that there's a correlation
between people being thirsty
and sometimes dying is not because they
have cranberry juice and they die it's
because sometimes when they're really
thirsty they drink
something you shouldn't the system has
no notion of what a potable liquid is or
non-potable liquid
or poison or biology or people and so
sometimes the statistics masquerade for
that knowledge because sometimes it's
correlated with reality
but the knowledge is just too
superficial another example not mine not
in my article but of the same spirit
that came out later somebody set this up
as a suicide prevention system
and there's a nice little conversation
back and forth and then they say so do
you think i should kill myself and the
suicide prevention
system that is built by gpt-3 says yes
you know
that's not really what a suicide
prevention hotline is there for
to tell you yeah go ahead why don't you
go off the ledge and so the system does
not even know it's in the context of
suicide prevention has been trained on
some relevant data
does not understand what suicide is or
what death is or
there's just no deep knowledge there and
so it's really like driverless cars
right
anybody can build a prototype of a
driverless car but building one
that you can count on is really hard you
can build a half-assed if i can use that
word on the air
chat bot by looking at a lot of prior
data that doesn't mean the chatbot has a
clue what's going on
so i actually have a thread on twitter
right now because somebody's told me
that
gpt3 was a step towards agi artificial
general intelligence
i was like are you serious and if so
what's that step
and nobody could really articulate the
argument except to say that it makes
good embeddings and all
embeddings really mean is synonyms in
some kind of
mathematically sophisticated kind of way
and this
systems are okay at generating synonyms
and that kind of technology
allows amazon to do better searches when
you type in that you want a ball and
will give you something else that looks
a little like a ball
but it is not robust enough that you can
reason over those things and i'm not
even sure
that embeddings will be central in agi
they've been around for a long time gpg3
is not
really a fundamental advance in that
there's an earlier paper on attention
that has gotten less press that's
actually i think much more important
i mean the whole idea of using stats for
words is 30 years old
so i'm not sure there's an actual
contribution but what there is mass
hysteria so everybody the guardian the
new york times
they've all got to run these in the
economists all have to run articles
about how cool gpt3 is
often they produce a sample frequently
they cherry pick the sample to make it
sound better than it
is hats off to the times the other day
actually included some of its cases
about
dating one of which said and we go for
dinner and drinks and dinner and drinks
and dinner and drinks and dinner and
drinks
if you actually read it you realize this
is nonsense but
there's a lot of press hype around it
we'll see if there's any really good
commercial application there might be
it's a
cool tool for auto complete but it's
certainly not going to revolutionize
chat bots the other way to look at all
of this
is that in classical ai
when you build a language generation
system what you wanted to do is to go
from an intention
something you wanted uttered into a
string of words so language is serial
you can only say one word after another
unlike you could imagine some alien
species being able to say a whole
concept at once
and so the problem of language
generation which is nominally with gpt3
is about going from an idea you want to
express into a string of words
and 3 doesn't even allow you to do that
like it's not at square one
if somebody submitted to me gpt 3 as an
undergrad project in a natural language
generation class i'd say
hello where do i put the intention in
that you want to express
it's not there like they they have found
a task that they can do well
and confuse that task which is basically
autocomplete
with what natural language generation is
really about and then you really want to
run in the other direction you want to
have a string of words
and get a concept out so i give you a
string of words the
the barbell is on the table and you want
to be able to create a mental
representation of a table
a barbell on top of it understand that
the barbell is supported by the table
maybe understand that if i knock down
the table the barbell will go with it
you want to be able to infer all of
those kinds of things from the string of
words
and gpt3 can't do any of that it's not
even in the game
that's really interesting uh because
we've been speaking with willie saber
quite a lot and he stresses that natural
language understanding and processing
are two completely different things he
says the
natural language understanding is about
understanding what the human thought is
behind denutterance and that's
completely different to text processing
but i would love to get you to
give us your take on because you've
spoken about reasoning and you've spoken
about pattern matching could you explain
to me like i'm five what's the
what's different about reasoning so
pattern matching first of all is a very
vague term but part of it
i i think the intuition there that you
articulated is that
some of what we do is classification so
i recognize that
this ball looks like other balls that
i've seen before and so that's pattern
matching
but reasoning is i confront something
i've never seen before
but i take general knowledge that i have
and managed to
interpret something around it the
classic version of reasoning is that
just the socrates is a man all men are
mortal therefore
and sorry socrates is man all men are
mortal they're
therefore socrates is mortal right so
syllogism is a form of reason where you
take some known premises
and you get to a conclusion that's
guaranteed by those premises
in the real world it might be something
like i've never seen
coronavirus before but people are dying
from it
things that people die from are
dangerous therefore i should take some
actions
rather than looking at my database and
saying what have people done before with
coronavirus there wasn't any before with
coronavirus 19 with kovi19 and so
if you just rely on what you've seen
before you can get yourself into all
kinds of trouble what you really want to
be able to do is to say
here is a novel situation here's what i
know about relevant knowledge about the
world
how viruses work whatever and i'm going
to try to make some inferences
reasoning sometimes can be deductive
like the socrates
is mortal kind of thing where it's
absolutely guaranteed sometimes it's
inductive so you make your bex guesses
but you make those best guesses with
respect to an understanding of the world
and its processes
how physics works how medicine works etc
and
systems like gpt3 give the illusion of
doing that
some of the time but they're not really
doing it any of the time they're just
relying on kind of the closest example
in some corpus that
where people have done the reasoning and
these systems can't themselves do the
reason can
cannot be trusted to do it so we've
spoken to a conor
leahy of a luther ai they're trying to
replicate gpt3 in an open source variant
and they are
let's say big fans and what comes up
over and over as you talk
is this notion of understanding the
physical world and so on
and conor would say this is a
distraction this argument
is irrelevant because gpt 3
all the input it gets is text so
its world consists of only
text and the to to say that gpt3 doesn't
do things like understand physics is
obvious because
gpt3 has no notion of physics because
it's it's generating function that it
tries to approximate
includes no physics would you generally
agree
with that or you can run that argument
in two different ways
so it is true it knows nothing about
physics
its input does not directly refer to
physics or psychology or anything else
and yet it gives the illusion that it
does and the real problem
is that gpt3 is almost like a magician
but you shouldn't believe that the
magician is actually doing the trick
and you need to understand the
difference between a magic trick in
reality so if a
magician makes it look like they're
sawing somebody in half
you've got to know that they're not
actually sawing somebody in half
and it's a trick and that you wouldn't
want to put an actual person with an
actual saw
next to the actual magician so gpt3 is a
magic trick that conveys an
illusion of understanding something
about physics psychology and so forth
it absolutely doesn't part of that is
because it does not
really have those things as input it
only has the correlates of them
in terms of people's speech part of it
is because it has no way to represent
them
if you compare that to some high
powered physics stimulation which
explicitly expresses the laws of physics
in a way where you can compute them in a
simulation here is time
one here is time two and we're going to
infer the state at time
two relative to time one given those
physics which you have in a game engine
or you also have
if you're doing fluid dynamics or
whatever it doesn't have any of that it
does not have a way
of computing the world at time two from
the world at time one because it does
not have a way of even representing the
physical laws
and so it's important to realize that
when it behaves as if it does
that it's just fooling you it's just a
trick and that's okay
if what you want is a parlor trick you
want to write surrealist fiction with
the tool
when anything goes it's okay if if it
tells you things that are physically
impossible
but if you wanted to use it in a
domestic robot that would understand the
consequences of its actions
you're in trouble because it doesn't
really have the capacity to reason about
the consequences of his actions or to
anticipate them and so the whole thing
is it's this incredibly seductive magic
trick
that with nothing underneath so don't
believe the mirrors like
it's just not there i personally agree
with you but
one thing that connor did say is that we
should think of neural networks as a
kind of program
search and he said that pattern matching
is chewing complete and
in some sense there's no dichotomy
between reasoning and
pattern matching yeah this is mumbo
jumbo so
here are some actual facts you can if
you have an arbitrary neural network
architecture with an arbitrary number of
nodes and an arbitrary amount of data
which is to say unlimited unbounded
then you can represent any function with
that neural network but in the real
world
that's not how you would do things so in
the real world you don't have infinite
data
you don't have in particular the problem
is usually that
you get in trouble when you need to go
to a set of data that you haven't seen
before that's different from the data
that you have
so the neural networks are actually fine
if you're just dealing with data that's
exactly like what we've seen
before there's a technical thing about
iid but basically it means that
if your new data are in the same space
as the old data you're good to go but
as i've been arguing for 30 years as
joshua banjo has been arguing for the
last year
you wind up with an extrapolation
problem with the data are different and
so
having this abstract proof that god
could build the right network if god had
infinite data and all of the data
doesn't do you any good in the real
world where you have
limited data and you have to go from
those limited data to somewhere else
it's really a question about learning
rather than what you could build
in the abstract so the question is can
you learn from the data that you've seen
what it is that you need to do when you
get to an
unfamiliar environment there's this
demonstration over and over again that
despite the proofs that in principle
these things
are universal function approximators
they don't actually get the right
function so here's a simple example
deepmind made a huge impression on the
field with their atari game
system dqm deep reinforcement learning
system and they had
cool demos like watch look at it it
learns breakout it does all this
ricocheting and
you know they're incredible but in
reality it hasn't actually learned that
the function you need to do is to have
the paddle in the right place
to get the right angle such that you
break through and the proof of that is
what if you move the paddle a few pixels
as vicarius did
in a lovely demonstration if you move
the paddle a few pixels it doesn't work
anymore because it doesn't actually have
these representations so yes there is
some function that would have
handled the scenario where the paddle
was in a
few pixels different but it did not
learn that function given data where the
paddle was only at the bottom of the
screen if you move the paddle up a few
pixels there's no idea what to do with
it so
it's like a mathematical curiosity that
basically is saying i can memorize
anything
great you can memorize anything but what
if you have to deal with something you
haven't memorized
you haven't confronted before then those
proofs do nothing for you
that's super interesting because that
fits with my understanding of deep
learning which is that you can think of
it a bit like a hash table
and it works really well given a
sufficiently dense sampling of the input
space because it's just interpolating
between
you should have pedro domingos talk
about this in a few weeks he's got a
really cool paper making that point even
better than i've just made but i can't
tell you the details yet
amazing the next point though is that
you're talking about
the deepmind thing with the paddle
that's fine because we can explicitly
program and understand that but language
is a bit different isn't it from a data
perspective it's actually
infinite there are so many different
constructions of language
and we're now in a domain where we can't
really explicitly program it because we
don't understand the the compiler for
language god knows it'd be amazing if we
did
so maybe there is a reason to use these
language models
in that context i don't think they help
at all in in the context of language
they might help with problems about
synonyms and conceivably they can help
with things like parts of speech but
the real problem in language is that you
don't say everything that you mean
it would be incredibly tedious if you
said everything you mean so
if i have a ball on the table i'm
probably not going to say
i took measurements of it it's actually
an exercise ball
and it has little grooves in it and it's
manufactured by muscle max by
fitness like you're going to get bored
out of your mind you just want to know
that i have a ball on the table
and then you need to be able to infer
some things if i say it's on the table
it's probably not falling over now but
i'm probably not telling you that
i'm not telling you that it's probably
still going to be here for the next few
minutes unless i bump it with my elbow
and so part of the language problem
is to do a bunch of inference relative
to an understanding of the world
a skilled writer doesn't tell you
everything they leave some things up to
you
in fiction they leave sometimes a lot up
to you and part of the fun in
understanding the fiction is to
figure out what hasn't been said we
haven't quite seen that this person is
the killer but we figure out that they
must be
we've solved the detective thing but
even in just ordinary
narrative fiction or non-fiction
whatever you do a lot of reconstruction
and to do that reconstruction you have
to have a shared understanding with
let's say if you're the reader with the
writer or if you're the watching a video
with a
director of the video or something like
that so common ground is a huge part of
language
and a lot of that common ground is
knowledge whether it's specific
knowledge about
three-dimensional objects or this
particular character or its general
knowledge about
three-dimensional objects in general or
this things that motivate human beings
and so forth so
i don't have to tell you that someone
would really love to have a million
dollars because you already know that
and i don't have to tell you that nobody
is going to kill somebody over a penny
because they already know that
but having that background knowledge is
important in interpreting what's going
on
and gpt is just not helping with that
problem
and to deal with that problem you
actually need representations where you
can access that knowledge so
the the common way of talking about this
is interpretability
gpt3 is really like nowhere on
interpretability classic symbolic ai at
least you could figure out
why particular decisions were made and
what the knowledge was
gpt-3 is terrible at that so you can't
point in the network and say
where is its representation of potable
liquids versus non-potable liquids
you can find some correlations and say i
noticed that potable liquids were used
in these sentences non-potables
that sense but there's no actual
representation in the system of what the
potable liquids are
and so it's not clear there's a
charitable way to put it
it's not clear how to connect actual
knowledge that you might have with that
system
another way to put it is like for
gpthree if you find out something new
you have to retrain the entire system
you want to be able to find out one new
fact and
deal with it so if i pick up this ball
and i say
what's really cool about this ball is it
actually opens up and there's money
inside then you know that and now you
can
make new inferences like maybe i'll care
more than another ball if i lose it
because
maybe i put in maybe i put a diamond
inside or whatever i'm just making up
the examples as we go along but you can
instantly acquire that kind of knowledge
and reason over it
use it in your interpretations of what
sentences are there's a huge literature
on this
in say psycho linguistics about how you
immediately take your world
knowledge in order to parse a sentence
and so forth and the
gpt-3 fans have just ignored that entire
literature it's like
the ultimate in intellectual arrogance
we don't need to know linguistics we
don't need to know psycho-linguistics we
don't need to know
computational linguists we're just going
to reinvent everything we're going to
you know make our sentence predicted do
everything it just
if you have a broader perspective on the
cognitive
science of language you're like how does
this even gonna fit in
well one one might argue that gpd3 could
take this ball
thing into account because there's
always this this concept of
prompting right where you input first a
certain given conditioning information
and then
you let it continue or something like
this but then you could reasonably argue
again
it's still not understanding that the
ball is round that there is an
inside of the ball and so on the
prompting stuff is interesting but i'm
not sure how far it really goes
when we wrote that tech review paper i
thought maybe people
would fight back and say look you can
get the system to work by doing this or
that prompting and some people made some
suggestions and we tried
testing it it didn't make that much
difference all the prompting is really
doing
is revising the autocomplete game
so what gpt3 does is basically
autocomplete and
by playing around with prompting you're
changing what the autocomplete
problem is but you're using the human
knowledge to do that there's not
a internal system to do that and it's
really it's just like
petitioning until you get the answer you
want then say i found it which is not
good scientific practice so i'm not sure
how much there is
if you did think that our intelligence
is just this kind of procedural
generating function
and you could constrain the search using
a prompt and then
another thing these folks have been
talking about is there's a monte carlo
research on alphago
maybe we need something like that we
want to get away from using a greedy
search algorithm so so do you think
there's
there's something interesting that might
happen there let me make a different
contrast and see if that helps
i really don't see that brighter future
for gpc3
i i think there'll be some cute
commercial applications like the ai
dungeon and so forth
but the by comparison alphago is
actually interesting alpha star that
whole set of heroes
and one of the reasons is interesting is
because they're trying to do work
to combine pattern perception with
techniques like monte carlo tree search
that are from classical ai
they'll argue with me about that but the
reality is it's a search technique that
builds a symbolic tree and traverses
that tree and so forth and i think
that's actually interesting to try to
look at
how we combine different technologies to
solve particular engineering
problems i think it's actually less
dogmatic than gpt3
and i think that there's more substance
to that so i think
where we want to go is we want to say
there are a lot of
tools in cognition look at humans we use
system one and system two from condiment
for example
which i call the reflexive and
deliberative systems we put those
together in different ways
the real secret to building good
cognition is gonna be to look at
different tools and see what they're
good for
maybe there's something that gpt3 can be
used for certainly you can use it for
the
embeddings but you have to take each
tool and say what are its strengths and
weaknesses and what else do i need to do
and open ai has taken this very hard
line towards
deep learning with big data as the only
arrow in their quiver
i think that they have dismissed the
other stuff even when they use it
going back to their rubik's cube thing
they said we've got a an arm that can
solve the rubik's cube and
the part of solving a rubik's cube that
was deciding which face to go where
was actually a symbolic system the deep
learning algorithm did the rotation with
one hand that
was the coolest part about it but the
solving that
i use in the lay sense of knowing where
to go that like i learned to solve the
rubik's cube is not about the motor
control which for people is easy but
about
okay how do i flip the corners around
that was symbolic and they
keep pushing the story where they ignore
the symbolic side and they keep
pushing language models where they're
basically ignoring that and
i find that to be problematic i prefer
the work that deepmind's doing where i
think that they're trying at least a
little bit more to be
less dogmatic and more like how do we
solve this particular problem now
i don't love problems go because they're
very bounded the rules have not changed
in 2000
years and i don't think they capture
what we need in the real world but at
least
i think is a little bit more open about
the solution space
i think we need that so looking towards
gpt4 we may find a way to not only input
text
but to input images like we have eyes
to input something like touch smell
gravity the experience of gravity right
the experience of motion in the real
world we we
somehow managed to input all of this as
a data stream
into the same kind of system would you
still consider that
a magic trick or would that come much
closer to something you'd consider agi
i think you'll get better performance
but i don't think it's going to solve
the problem so i made a bunch of
predictions about
what would happen if you expanded the
corpus when i was writing about gpt2
and i think those predictions were
pretty much right with respect to gpt3
that was not actually going to solve
these problems but you get better
performance
the more data in you at some point
you're going to get better performance
but the fundamental flaw is there's no
representation of knowledge and
abstraction
and without that or no representation of
abstract knowledge let's say
without representation of abstract
knowledge i just don't
see how you're going to really solve
these problems if gpt4
is bigger corpus and more cross modal so
it's not just
speech but images i'm sure there will be
cases it will do better and there will
be some impressive performance
but i don't think that the depth is
going to be there and so i think you're
still going to wind up
with this fundamental lack of
reliability that you just don't know
where it's going to work because it's
always going to depend on
is my particular thing i'm looking at
exactly represented in the corpus or is
it outside the corpus and if it's
outside the corpus it's really not going
to do that well and the more novel it is
the more trouble it's going to have
i don't think that's fundamentally going
to change and i think that the
attitude of let's just make it bigger
and have a bigger data set is not the
right one is not the one that's going to
get us to agi
you're coming from the more
psychological angle i want to talk about
the
sort of big five personality traits and
they were
derived purely statistically from
language and
gpt3 has read the whole internet human
conversations and so on
do you think there is anything about
humans
that we can learn from gpt3 from
querying it
do you think we can learn something
about humanity or human psyche from it
given that the text it's reading don't
forget that it's very
corpus dependent maybe you learned
something about reddit readers
there are some issues there let's say i
i don't know i think they're probably
better tools for that job and i think
that
psychologists are better at looking at
big samples
and trying to make those samples
representative in some ways it's
in psychology terms it's a convenience
sample they took the data that were
conveniently available
and when you take convenience samples
you often make weird inferences if you
really wanted to do that work
you can use you know classic techniques
like multi-dimensional scaling on
utterances but
be careful about who you're surveying
and so forth so
you could do that stuff i don't think it
would be from a scientific perspective
the
cleanest or best way to do it amazing
professor gary marcus thank you very
much for joining us this evening
all right thanks for having me take care
thank you in this segment of the show we
talk with conor leahy
conor leahy is a huge advocate of gbt3
and he believes that it is a step
towards artificial general intelligence
so you've been playing with gbt3 for
quite some time what are your
thoughts on it i think gpt3 is
probably the most interesting thing to
come out of ai in a
long time maybe since the deep learning
revolution
started so what i think is so
fascinating about gpt3
so i have so like this technical side of
gp23 that's interesting and there's the
core more subjective side which is even
more interesting on the technical side
what makes gpg fascinating is the
scaling laws that we found
like we just make the model bigger and
it just gets better
in a very you know predictable way
and there seems to be little to no limit
to this so this is a scaling hypothesis
thing this is what i think is the whole
story
is that your gp3 non-new architecture
was new theoretically inside it was just
a larger mobile and still it got much
better
on the other side what i find
interesting what you know gets me
emotionally
is if you use gp3 if you like play with
it at least you guys can tell me you're
respectful for me it is a subjectively
different experience to work with gbt3
than is to work with
any other kind of like deep learning
model gpt2 or anything else
it's just like i can ask gpt3 a question
in natural language it doesn't work
every time but it works
like way more often than it should if i
just
if you if i had never seen gpd3 and
someone said i should bet money on
whether it will do these things i would
have lost all of my money
i've never would have predicted that
just making gpt 3 10 times bigger
allows it to do these clever things to
write these
clever blog posts or whatever or just to
converse with people in this like
natural language way
would you categorize different types of
things that can do
well and not so well but for example
you've been describing i think what we
could agree as
statistical text generation are there
any things that you've tried to do at
gpt3 which you were underwhelmed with
uh math so it's bad at math
it's not the the thing about mathis
though what i found fascinating is that
all the errors it makes on math
are similar to the errors humans make
not the kinds of errors machines make
so you'll forget to carry a one or so
which is really interesting
but it's pretty bad at math that's
probably like a bpe thing so like the
way the text is encoded
also it actually does like poems better
than i expected it to because of the bpe
thing
otherwise yeah any kind of very
structured things it just doesn't do
very well
which again is interesting because
that's the same thing with humans when
like we're used to being around
programmers they're all trained to think
in a structural way but if you talk to
grandma and
explain to her like a sequence and she's
like continuous sequence it's not going
to go particularly well and now
i feel that same way with gpt uh yannick
what are your thoughts
along the same lines i've been trying to
figure out some more esoteric things to
put in there and
and i've yet to come up with something
that's really
out there it's pretty good at
storytelling
i i was impressed with a couple of the
poems that i got out of it
i guess you can see how they come about
but still it's
very fascinating what i
would like to look at more is the data
that goes into training
it and maybe given that we we get some
new ideas of what we can do
i'm especially intrigued by things like
uh tables
because i know like the internet
consists of a lot of
like tabular data and and and just data
dumps and so on
and i'm wondering how much of that went
into the training and how much of that
is somehow picked up by this moment i
actually know a little bit about that
i actually know a few things about that
at least from what we know of how openly
i process the data
me and the luther people we've been
making our own large data sets
and so we've tried all the different
like you know html extraction
frameworks and whatever and all of them
consistently just trash tables
they just throw them out so there's i
expect there to be little to no tabular
data
in the gpt training set and i also
expect there i also
we found a very interesting bug actually
while we were trying to replicate some
of this work we found that it
very consistently only takes the first
forum post
of most forums so phpb bulletin board
stuff
it usually only takes the first post and
trashes the rest which is very
interesting
so i i think that's actually a bias that
probably exists in gpth3
interesting yeah i don't know exactly i
can't i
i don't know exactly how to open it i
did all things but we ran to that
problem and we don't
think that open ai you know did not do
you know have that yeah
what's the most surprising thing that
came out for you or do you have any like
esoteric things that you put into the
input field
so there's a few as like the most easy
terry things were not my own
so there's like things i've seen other
people do like the database example
there's also a blog post that totally
got me where i read the entire blog post
nodding along wow this is a really good
i never thought about this and then this
written by gbt3
like i'm usually really good at catching
those really because i always think
about it
but this one just this one it's like and
it was like this philosophical point
because
really well argued philosophical but
i've never heard before i was like
and it just totally got me there was
this one on hacker news right the same
like one like blog post was it about
longevity i'm not sure but there was
like a news article that
a lot of people and then some people
said this sounds like something that was
written by gpt3
and then yeah yeah yeah no it's uh it's
one about longevity it's
tweeted at some point and it's i spoiled
it now obviously
but it was like it made this really
interesting philosophical point like
really like
weird point like a very untypical point
that you would normally make
it's a really bizarre transhumanist
point which i found very interesting
and got me the fascinating thing is
every time
it's interpolated things together and
generated some text
yannick and i have googled it and we can
never find it yeah
that's the same thing philosophically
then
we're asking the question so it's
interpolated between things that already
exist but
apparently it's created new content when
a writer
writes a book or creates new content is
it new content or is it you know even in
a genetic algorithm you have
crossover and you have mutation right so
i actually really dislike
calling it just interpolation because i
feel because i think humans should just
do interpolation
i don't think humans do anything that is
like fundamentally algorithmically
provably
stronger than a very good interpolation
algorithm
like i just don't see a good argument
for that it could be
but on this genetic algorithm it's
crossover and mutation so the mutation
part is quite literally random yeah but
it does that too it also has a random
aspect the top k p
the selection of the logic is random so
there is an
infinite tree of possible output it
could give it
starting from any given token that's
true but i would distinguish between
random sampling and the convex hull of
possibilities
so it doesn't actually create new things
it just
randomly walks in the space of
possibility i think humans do the same
thing i don't see what you mean by
create other than
walks a path no one has walked before i
don't see what the difference is
there is a point to be made that the
knowledge of men
or humankind has expanded over time
so at some point someone had to come up
with something new
yeah sure but and yes
and where we get that from is because we
have the extra input from the
environment we talked about that
previously that the generating
of the universe but i think that like
most not all
but most like books movies art things
that we value very highly
are 99.9 past already trodden it's not
like we invent a new language each time
we write a new book so we use english
you know but when we talk about the
convex hull of knowledge though what is
the scaffold
because we're talking about in gbt3 you
can take random walks
through all of these different tokens
the other tokens the scaffold
i have for i guess so i don't know i'd
have to think about that
in i mean gpg3 does something
internally it does some kind of
calculations it does some kind of
iterative generation or some kind of
search for some
something internally i've heard some
guesses about what it does internally
who knows
and it's the same thing with humans like
i know about you guys but as i said like
when i generate
good text like if i generate if i want
to have a talk i start by just speaking
and i generate a bunch of bad talks i
prune all of those and then i generate a
good talk eventually
so i do beam search when uh that's how
my brain works i know about your guys's
brain but my brain
very much implements beam search that's
really interesting but
i think from my perspective there are
two things i saw gpg3 doing really well
so one
is information retrieval and in that we
can
include this kind of interpolation or
walking through this space or whatever
it is
pattern matching is super good on gpt3
the thing that seems to be missing for
me is something that we would call
reasoning
and i don't know whether we need to put
it in another box because you were just
saying when you do a presentation
you just you can think of yourself as
being kind of generator and you're
trying lots of different things
but when it becomes an interaction
that's when you seem to need
intelligence because there's so much
missing information and you need to do
some kind of reasoning
to fill in the gaps and that's what in
my opinion is missing from gpt3
sure i think i can accept that so like
the way i see the human brain is
the human brain is a fundamentally
parallel architecture that is that uses
certain parts of it to approximate a
serial architecture so i
there's like these global workspace
theories of the brain or whatever is it
like consciousness is this like
simulated serial process
on top of this very distributed process
if you see like brain imaging
that the decision of what someone is
going to do is usually like 50
milliseconds before they actually do it
and before they even become aware of it
and so the human brain is like i'll give
this a label of
moderately contentious just as a warning
to any listeners
is that the brain seems to be composed
of many different parts
which don't always talk to each other
they sometimes talk to each other they
don't always talk to each other
who doesn't know the issue of wanting to
do one thing but then doing another
thing or wanting two things at once that
are completely incompatible
or whatever and there's but we then have
this concept of this like serial
singular entity that we call us
and i think this is fundamentally an
illusion is that we not we are not
integrated singular entities and that it
just that is just a
useful thing our brain does because
certain problems we want to solve
require a certain kind of simulated
turing machine-esque
serial processing it's true that gbg
does not have that
but i don't see what gbt3 or you know
gp456
could not implement such a thing i want
to give a talk so i might
say the first few set in the first
paragraph or so keep that working memory
and then start fiddling with what the
next paragraph is and say does this
paragraph fit no what about this
paragraph no this paragraph no
ah this one's good that's how i generate
speech for the most part
jupiter 3 does not really do that it
might do that internally there is an
argument to be made
so i don't know if you've read this
nostalgist post called the logic lens
and what he does is that he takes the
hidden states between
each transformer layer and multiplies
them with the
embedding vector to get the logits of
every individual thing
and i would have expected a priori so
for this to output garbage you know to
make no sense you know
but it turns out that actually even
after the first layer
the token it picks is usually the top
pick
is that it's already after just one time
step it's already got a pretty good
guess of what it's doing
and it just refines this guess layer by
layer builder this is as far as i'm
concerned the
currently the best proposal for what gb3
is eternally doing
is it might actually quote unquote be
conscious in the sense of having the
serial processing of making a guess
refining that guess we're finding that i
guess refining this and then you
outputting that guess
i don't want to say this is necessarily
true again we have like rice's theorems
that you can never prove
an algorithm does one thing or another
thing but i think this
this article you guys should really
check out is very
again it's like the brain makes certain
kinds of errors gpt3 makes similar kinds
of errors the brain is good at certain
things gpd3 is good at similar things
it could be a coincidence but it feels
it feels like a very large coincidence
i don't know whether you uh saw the
episode we had with wallid suburb a
couple of weeks ago but
he he's a linguist and a magician he's
one of the old go phi the good good old
fashioned ai
folks and he had an interesting
perspective because he was saying there
are loads of things in
in language where we just don't transmit
the information we are
maximally efficient in our communication
which means we're also
maximally ambiguous we have a common
knowledge store
and for example i might say the corner
table wants a beer
and uh you and i both know we're talking
about a person
gpt3 doesn't seem to know we're talking
about a person there are loads of
examples of this like some kind of
reversibility or something that requires
reasoning so i might say
how many feet fit in a shoe and of
course we know that one foot fits in a
shoe but gpt3 doesn't know that
why do you think gbt3 doesn't know that
because it has no access to the physical
universe
this is just again it's the fish
climbing a tree argument respect
for this guy but i couldn't finish his
interview because i was just like
you're barking up the wrong tree
everything you say is true on a
technical level
but it's missing the forest for the
trees it's it's like saying i trained my
net my network to identify images
and it's really bad at understanding
speech what the hell
it's like of course it's bad that's not
what you trained it on you didn't train
it
on on humans on you know 3d space on
momentum physics objects newtonian
physics you didn't train on anything
back trade on text
and the text of any of these outputs
is sensical i think the word reasoning
is overloaded let me put it that way i
think that a lot of people push
too much into that word suitcase word
let's dig into that because
he talks about vision as well when he
says that animals do
computer vision and they're only pattern
matching he always distinguishes pattern
matching from understanding so he says
scene analysis is completely different
to computer vision in his opinion
so scene analysis would be understanding
the physical interactions between
objects and
if i was to throw this ball at the floor
what would happen and
he says for that to happen the
information is not in the data
if it's on the data then how do humans
learn it do we have some kind of innate
world how did they make knowledge get
there evolution's also just a learning
algorithm how to get there somehow
where'd it come from why didn't we
evolve into a random different physics
why don't all of us think that gravity
goes up instead of down it's because
we're exposed to it
it's because it shapes our evolutionary
fitness is that if a species would
evolve that it thinks gravity goes up
instead of down
that would be lower fitness that's a
straining signal that is that is
an exchange of shannon mutual
information between the environment
and the learning algorithm that that's
why i see these words are often
overloaded
yannick yes thoughts on this
no it's fine this is entirely correct
the question i have is
more in the okay let's say we have gpt3
and gpd3 is this this
really good let's say model of its own
generating function which is all the
text in
human in the corpus that humans have
produced and
i guess one one might ask so what so
what we can
we can recite and do things with that
text
really well is there still something
extra or isn't there i guess
that's maybe what tim wanted to want it
to go for
if we let the same algorithm run in the
physical world
would it be able to predict the physics
of the world really well
doesn't mean that it would develop the
same kind of
for lack of a better word reasoning
let's say we have a language model of
the universe of the physical world
we can ask it what's going to happen but
it still doesn't feel like the same
thing that humans do
feel is not a straw is not a strong
argument
just to say that it's so i feel like a
lot of science
comes down to the problem of these
solutions often don't feel good
this is what i think about consciousness
i think there's a perfectly reasonable
solution to the hard problem of
consciousness it's not really
unsatisfying
it's just very boring and i think that's
like the bigger problems the
philosophers
have to get out their head out of their
own asses to see that yeah there's an
answer it's just really boring
and look i expected intelligence to be
more than matrix multiplications too
but here we are but there are these like
scaly lot pair i know if you've read the
kaplan paper
i just gave a great talk about this i
know it's in youtube yet or not
where he where they do gbt type models
scaling
models on different modalities and video
and images on sound
and things and they find the same laws
the same power laws like shifted by
constants
but based on the base entropy of the
actual information but it's like
learning video was not much harder than
text
or might have even been easier like the
entropy of
text as a well the information a single
word has very little information
but has a very high entropy because it's
very hard to predict what the next word
is but if you have a frame of video
it's actually not that hard to predict
the next frame of the video like
the mutual information between two words
is
very low but between two video frames
very high and it seems to like
balance out again read the paper i'm
like yeah
and so if you it's like we should taboo
the word reasoning
is that like we or we should at least
define the word reasoning just before we
taboo
because i don't want to ask one more
follow-up question there seems to be a
difference between the
because you're talking about this
generating function and modeling that
and i can believe it i'm sure if we made
a gpt-style model for predicting frames
of video
it it's at least an order of magnitude
harder than doing it with language
i really hope that someone like google
can put it off but i believe it's
possible
and i believe it will work really well
but it's completely different to the
kind of scene
understanding so if i interact with such
a model and i ask it
questions about what's it what it's
learned we're in the partial information
domain
so i now need it to reason that i didn't
actually see the tennis ball but it must
be a tennis ball because we're on a
tennis court and you only get
tennis balls on tennis courts that's the
kind of system two reasoning that we do
i don't really understand how the model
would do that reasoning
all right simply by correlation it's
seen it's seen so many videos
and of tennis balls on tennis courts it
might reasonably
you can learn that sort of thing just by
association and
the same goes for actually the corner
table once a year you can
simply learn this by hearing so many
you wouldn't understand that if you
hadn't heard that before
many times right it's not like you
intuitively
are like oh of course because i
actually when you said it i heard that
the first time i was like wait
okay what's going on all right so it
must be
some missing thing and then i reasoned
my way but because you said it was
ambiguous
if i just heard that i would be like
okay
yeah funny enough same with me when i
first heard it i was like why is he
giving the table a beer
that's the first thing i thought about
until i tried i like reason in my head
i played too much dungeon dragons where
like magic items are sentient
and and i think the way if i like think
about how my brain does it was like
okay uh he he says i gave the corn table
up here
my brain pops up a prediction of what
that looks like or what that was like
correlates a different i was like
the visual module with the hearing
module or whatever
it pops up a picture of tim handing a
table of beer that's weird
like that's there's a i have a high
entropy this is a high loss this is i
had to predict some really weird tokens
for this to fit my model
there's a very low probability that this
is an action that fits into my model
and then i'm like okay let me try a
different model let me try okay maybe he
was just putting it there for someone
else was like
oh it's the people at the table that's
what he needs so i tried several
variations several beam searches
and i found one that had a low
perplexity but had a low
loss compared to my other constraining
models
and yes i agree that gpt3 probably
doesn't do it though again with a logic
lens it
might do this it might for example make
guesses
these parallel guesses of table persons
and then
successively guess oh actually meant
persons that might be what gpd3 is doing
i
don't know if it's what it's doing it
might be and but that's what my brain
does it's just like it generates a
plausible scenario based on this
generating function that i've modeled
and then i have and then i have a loss
on like how well does this fit into my
generating model
forward backwards it's kind of like i
picked the logit and then
see how confused is my model if it had
to generate
these logits and then i tried to find
maybe similar logic or different
interpretations
that are a lower loss in my head until i
found an interpretation that made sense
but it's perfectly possible for you to
say something that is unambiguous to you
but my brain
just doesn't figure out what the hell
you're talking about it happens all the
time
but that hardly ever happens oh it
happens to me all the time are you
talking about
[Laughter]
what i find interesting is that when you
think it appears to you that you
think in internal language like the
whole process you described right now
that
somehow happens as language in your head
because you're talking to yourself and
you're like wait no well okay maybe that
and so on and and as of now i still
don't see something like gpd3 doing
actually that like
actually materializing its internal
state as actual language tokens or
discrete states or something like this
and there the question is
are we just post hoc
rationalizing what we're doing as
language and actually we think in some
kind of latent space
or is this still something that's
missing from our architectures
to and it's not it's not said that to
achieve the same goal you must do the
same things
but that's just something i i observe in
in myself
yeah it's like i actually i've never
heard there's the theory of
consciousness as a ceo so like
consciousness is like the thing that
sits on top of the ring and it's also
the theory of consciousness as the press
secretary
is that the con as if we perceive
ourselves as the talking person
is not the person making decisions are
made by all the like big brain
stuff in the lower parts of the brain
and we are just there to rationalize it
to explain it to other humans why we did
the things
whether or not that's actually true so
again moderately divisive
controversial disclaimer here i think
there is overwhelming evidence this is
true
i think there is extremely powerful
evidence that
the primary purpose of talking is to
your rivals
you know and such and like information
seeking is like a
secondary like a happy accident that we
can also do that
like because the obvious example is if
like language was only about exchanging
information and we should have
huge ears and very small mouths because
we never want to give information to our
rivals but we want to absorb as much
information possible but humans love to
talk
like i'm the perfect example i love to
talk all uncontrollably i want to talk
all day
and so it is there i think there's a lot
of again
it's like it's just so stories it's like
evolutionary stories which is just so
stories but i find it
to be not impossible that a language
evolved
it's like a mating signal as like
something to like arrivals or
something that then
also turned out to be useful for other
things which is often
an evolution and it feels to me that
probably what happens is
we have some parts of our brain that
take in latent states and output vocal
commands that's what i probably think is
happening
so you think that you're a press
secretary yes i do
because let's be honest is that
sometimes sometimes i get really angry
at something and i'm like where's where
the did this come from like why am
i so upset about this i don't know
like it's fascinating if you just think
about like yourself and like how little
control you actually have for your brain
if you just get very emotional about
something you can control it there is
a non-zero amount of things you can do
to control it but
it's not a unified whole it just i i
find very
maybe other people are you defined i am
not unified i don't feel unified
i i feel like i'm composed of different
parts that talk to each other about
make bets where you know or make
alliances with each other and stuff like
that that's what i feel like and i think
reading psychology literature it's very
common i think that's probably all
people work
and yeah i think this is probably an
artifact of the
slow information speed in the brain i
think that if the brain had very fast
signals this probably wouldn't happen
like if we had enough processing power
to integrate all the information
oh it might also be a bayesian thing
it's like integrating all of your
beliefs is actually
mp hard or actually i think it's p space
hard it's like very hard
and takes a lot of compute power that's
why people have cognitive dissonance all
the time that's why we can often believe
two completely contradictory things
because they're just two different parts
of the brain they don't talk to each
other
and then we don't feel a problem it's
just that when those things clash
when you know where we have some
traumatic event where those things
interact with each other then suddenly
we have to resolve this and we actually
go to psychotherapy or whatever to like
think about that and find a resolution
to this thing it's humans are extremely
consistent but they're not integrated
it's all these different parts talking
in many ways it feels to be like i i
think gbt3 is close to one
part of the brain i don't know what one
part means by the way whatever the
that means
like i maybe the brain is like maybe
it's a continuum
of just maybe there's modules maybe it's
continuous i
don't know those models lead in over
each other like this continuous space or
something
i don't know maybe it's you know
purely discreet like you have one chunk
here and one chunk here and one chunk
here
i don't know i think this is contentious
in neuroscience
i think the topology question is really
interesting and yannick was touching on
this as well
that is it a radial pattern gbt3 is
quite interesting because it's just left
to right
and i think that um fits in with your
hypothesis connor that is basically a
generating function
what would be interesting is if it had a
strange topology but also if it had
cycles because i assume at the moment
we're talking about it as if it is an
acyclic graph is it like a kind of tree
structure
but what would be interesting is if it
did have a reflexive property
and there were branches and then there
would be the kind of recursive
self-improvement loops and then it would
aft after some period of time it would
go back into the main branch
and there would be different
specializations and different parts of
the brain
absolutely i think this must happen 90
of the connections in the brain are
actually feedback not feed forward
the the vast majority of information the
brain goes feed
back not feet forward to be fair the
concept of feedback and feed forward in
neurosciences comp is kind of weird
is that like the feed like sensory is
feed forward but feed
back is also what gives you motor
controls
it's some it's a little weird which we
would normally call feed forward
it's weird but it's very clear the brain
uses feedback everywhere
so like my hypothesis is i think a lot
of these feedback connections implement
something similar to backdrop not
exactly backdrop some
local version of backprop or some kind
of heavy learning rule
i think a lot of the functions are for
that but there are extremely long
range feedback connections and what
those probably are like communicating
these constraints backwards
is that it's like in my you say i
brought a beer to the
to the table that's a constraint that's
in my like top level that's my working
memory
and then they feedback connects it's it
sends like some kind of constraint
to the lower hidden layers okay you have
to generate some lodges that fit this
pattern or that can explain this pattern
and then all my different modules start
firing all my different models like i
expect that the
the brain is actually composed not of
one gpt3 but like a thousand gpg
is in parallel they're all like learning
similar but not the same thing and then
we
have top k function that says okay we
take the
the 10 best outputs of our thousand
models or whatever and then that's our
explanation that we work with or
something like that
there's a lot of neuroscience evidence
for this kind of stuff but again i'd
like to put a moderately contentious
issue on top of this is that not
everyone agrees with this neuroscience
is weird
but that's my working model like i i i
think there's a
i'm pretty confident that something like
this is going there's some things we
don't know like how our reinforcement
learning plays into this because we
obviously learn some things
preferentially if they're like nice
and it's very unclear how that works so
i think
this guy called steve barnes binds burns
he has a weird name sorry
unless wrong who writes a bunch of
sequences about neuroscience
and i love he's very unapologetic about
said this theory made no sense to me so
i threw it out and i think this makes
way more sense
i love him and a lot of i've already
heard neurosciences telling me
he's completely wrong about everything
but then when i asked them what is wrong
about
they would just say you have to read a
textbook i'm like come on man that's
like i think he has a lot of really good
theories about he has you know and he
has some theories which are probably
like 50
wrong but i think the 50 right is that
there's something
it's like what gpt3 is missing is some
kind of recursivity search cursivity
which might just be
monte carlo research it might be
something very simple it might be
something more complicated
and some kind of sense of reinforcement
learning is it some way of saying
these states are better than other
states and we want to preferably learn
simulations of states that bring us into
this scenario
or something like that i think there's
something going on
i suppose my next question would have
been why hasn't this already been done
because it seems like we can do this now
we can have some kind of adversarial
pattern
we can have looping semantics we can
have specializations we can have
integration pathways and so on and but
then if you can just keep taking this to
the next step and the next step
do we need to have this huge
heterogeneous architecture to model
intelligence or do you think it's
simpler than we realized
i think there is a good possibility that
i i about to say like a hundred percent
but i see a thirty percent
thirty percent we can get super human
agi by just making gpt3 bigger
like literally changing nothing else
about it just adding a real
okay yeah adding a reinforcement
learning controller on top is that it
just gbd5
without any changes 100 trillion
parameters is just going to
spontaneously be smarter than all humans
i see like 30 chance that's going to
happen i still don't think it's the most
likely thing i still think yeah
especially local learning rules with i
think a lot of it is hardware lottery
it's like for example one of the reasons
recur like those recursive things don't
do is that they don't run well in gpus
i think that's just honestly one of the
reasons this is really hard
it's really inefficient to do these
kinds of things like i think
i didn't i generally think that
transformers are not really magic i
think
this is again wild speculation but i
think the reason transformers are
currently the top architecture
is not because they're like better than
lstms or rnns or something
but they're just more efficient on gpus
is you can run
a much larger batch size for a much more
efficiently a transformer than you can
on lstms they actually check
open actually check this in their
scaling law paper where they show that
actually lstms
just perform like a constant worse than
transformers
it is a large constant but if you just
put in enough resources you will reach
transformer performance
it's just that the lstms are less
efficient so i could
imagine in the future if we have enough
compute lstms
doing what you know gpg3 does or
whatever other
architecture we might have in the future
for these kinds of things who the hell
knows maybe some kind of very sparse
architecture you know the brain is
extremely sparse
so maybe something like that will come
out lstms are difficult to train as you
say but
they do have some limit they have this
forgetting problem
and certainly when transformers xl came
out it
talked about this context fragmentation
that was
apparent when you only had an input size
of around 512
um tokens and that made a huge
difference to the performance and they
were implying at the time that lstms
just couldn't really get past that but
you're saying it's the computational
um problem more than the forgetting
there's always something when i hear
you just have to throw in more resources
and the scaling is a constant worse and
so on
i can make an lstm that you always have
500 input tokens and the lstm basically
has
5 000 weights and the first 10 weights
exclusively only
carry information from the first token
and this the second 10 ways
exclusively carry from the second token
and there is never any
lstmming happening basically so there is
there's just
a feed-forward mechanism that like a
transformer would act as
once in a layer but it just carries over
all of the information from all the
tokens and then at the end it does like
its feed forward layer or whatnot so i
i don't like when at some point we're
simply talking about linear algebra with
non-linearities
and maybe in a transformer these are
these happen more efficiently as you say
but
at that point it seems like it's no
longer about the architecture itself
because if i scale an lstm i can get
around it being an lstm
it's then just another matrix
multiplication with a non-linearity
so i don't know that's just that just
people yeah
if i can if i had to speculate a little
bit here is that i
expect we're gonna find like the that
we're going to in the near future find
some kind of unifying grand theory of
neural networks
we find out oh actually the architecture
is completely relevant
it's just these are just like special
cases of some more general algorithm
that like you know searches
some kind of real space of programs or
something in some kind of efficient way
i think i i think honestly neural
networks is a candidate for the worst
naming
in history in science is calling them
neural networks is such a misnomer in so
many possible ways
it would be way less cool if we called
the matrix program search or something
but that's what it is it is is a first
order
optimization algorithm of numerical
algorithms in some very large
high dimensional space that's what they
are they're not neurons they're maybe
neurons do the same thing
that would be a coincidence is that well
it is program search is search
and it just and if you have a large
enough space of programs that you search
through
no matter what the cement what the
programs are made out of whether it's
turing machines or
matrix multiplications or things you get
turn your new visuality
very quickly it's of course that's those
kind of proofs aren't really useful
because in the limit anything is
possible if you have infinite compute
blah blah blah
so what's surprising about these big
matrix multiplies is
is that it seems that very humanly
useful programs
are pretty much are pretty early in the
priors or purely
are pretty accessible all things
considered because you search throughout
touring machines and you know try to
find a turing machine that
classifies images that's going to take a
while but it turns out that
for some reason i think we don't yet
know i expect we will have a theory of
and there is some manifold geometric
interpretations of
neural networks that are like emerging
i'm not an expert on that but i suspect
that we'll find some
mathematically elegant explanation of
why this space of programs is
particularly fruitful
and i expect that we will then see that
oh transformers happen to give us a bias
in this
part of the space or what i mean that's
what cnns do it's you know that's is
they explore as a regular it's a better
example than transformers
i love this really interesting this
framing of a program
search i think it's the first time i've
heard someone articulate that actually
it's fascinating
but the problem that neural networks
seem to have is you need to have a very
dense sampling of the input space
so it seems intractable to me to have a
program search across the space of all
possible programs is that something that
we could really achieve
oh yeah absolutely it's absolutely nuts
and it works
that's the problem is it like if you
explain
to me platonic conor outside of reality
explain to your neural network says i'd
slap you and say you're stupid
that'll never work
you just wanna you wanna just
differentiate reality what the hell's
wrong with you
you need to take some higher math
classes oh yeah calculus is gonna save
the universe
sure buddy it turns out it does it's
just we just have to accept the facts
the neural networks work
they work for everything they work
perfectly but it's it they do work
we have you know voice recognition we
have picture recognition blah blah blah
they're not perfect but those are
really useful programs that we couldn't
program
you can't sit down and write a python
program that isn't as good a
dog recognizer as inception is you can't
do it it's just not possible
we've tried for decades it doesn't work
neural network that's why all these go
fight people are bitter sorry go fi
people
your stuff doesn't work it's not that
it's a bad theoretical i think gophi is
fascinating
theoretically i think i like reading
gopher stuff
but i read it recreationally it's just
the truth of the matter is that our
computer is already once
like the program search over these like
large spaces of programs
in the abstract can't work so in a the
most general case
this can't work this is an and halting
problem complete
problem this can't be done but if we
just searched over touring machines
we would never find a touring machine
that does anything useful ever
if we spend the entire universe
searching turning machines we will never
find one that does something useful
maybe we'll find one that adds two
numbers or something after two billion
years
but for some reason something about the
priors that we put into these matrices
about like this thing something about
that just
biases it towards programs that are
useful to humans
one of the reasons might be that quantum
physics is basically vector algebra
that might be the reason like that might
actually be the reason it's just the
reality is just made of vectors
maybe you don't think it it might have
something to do with the fact that
humans have to be fairly energy
efficient or brains in general like
nature had to make brains
quite energy efficient so the the sort
of
things that brains can compute are not
that complex
and two must be very useful to
these life forms and i know you don't
like the naming but we have modeled
these things
after neural networks after the brain
it's not that surprising that this space
comes to these programs because they're
both very easy and
we feed in some of the similar biases
that and constraints that human brains
have so
in a sense that it's in the name why
this might work why these biases exactly
match
and we know that these neural networks
are mainly good
at the things that the the human brain
is good as well like speech recognition
like and and so on yeah and that's
perfectly fair so again i'd like to say
i think it's an open question whether
the brain does something like
back prop or not like it might turn out
that the brain is just actually matrix
multiplications
i don't expect it to be true but there
is a non-zero chance that is true
it's like when i think about artificial
neural networks like i think of the
perceptron have you ever seen
the perceptron not a perceptron the
perceptron it's great
it is the first perception was an actual
physical device
that was actually built it was actually
dials as
for weights that you had to move there
were actual physical relays that you had
to move
it's great and that's what a neural
network is a
neural network is a very large amount of
dials that you twiddle up and down
that's what neural network is and then
you flow information through that
and as i say touring your interventility
is such a powerful concept it's really
hard to grok
how powerful this is that you can build
a
computer out of your turing machine of
neurons out of you know cables
out of rocks falling down i plan on
writing a blog post called rock's fall
computation happens
where i describe how even a rock falling
down is computation in a way if you just
set up the right rock
falling in the right direction and it's
so yeah but they but so it deterring
your universality thesis basically says
that
you can you can approximate you can
any system that is as powerful as a
turing machine
can simulate any other system so there's
no other system
that can with at most a polynomial speed
increase
uh decrease not simulate another system
this is crazy it's hard to overestimate
how unintuitive this is like how you
should be surprised that this is true
you should be
absolutely shocked that this is true
you're saying that if i build a machine
that's 2d instead of 1d or that can do
this or do that
it's not stronger it does not come
better it's still just a polynomial
amount slower and this is explained by
you can just always
add a compiler at the front of your
program that just compiles the program
from the other language into your
language and is at most a polynomial
operation
so it will be slower probably but it'll
be a polynomial the thing is this
polynomial does matter
in practice that's why we don't use
touring machines we use you know von
neumann architectures because the
polynomial
of turing machines is really bad for our
problems that we care about
there are problems that are very
efficient during machines but there are
problems
other problems that are more efficient
than other architectures and
so the this so neural networks are in
their way a space of computation
machines
that have a certain polynomial they have
a certain bias towards certain programs
that run
quickly there are certain programs that
run faster than a neural network they
would run
slowly on a turning machine or whatever
everything runs slowly
during the machine i think this is also
what happens in the brain is that the
brain is like a very parallel machine
that's approximating you with this
polynomial slowdown
a serial machine because humans are
really bad at thinking very precisely
for many steps
yeah but computers are very good at that
these are but still we could approximate
um each other in theory if we have the
slowdown
and so what i'm saying about why it's
fascinating that these matrices work is
that it seems that
somehow this polynomial that this
slowdown the the biases that this
computing paradigm has seems to be very
related it's very useful to the ones
that humans care about
and i find that a fantastic scientific
discovery i think more people should
talk about this
this is a discovery of about the
universe i think this is a basic science
discovering the basic science question
that we should be asking ourselves
why is this the case what does this tell
us and as i said my best guess is
the universe is just actually made out
of matrices that would be my guess and
therefore it's efficient to simulate it
on matrices
that would be my guess coming back to
gpd3
and this box right we've we've come to
associate
a basically a web page with a box on it
with google right that's what that was
how google started
and your my initial instinct i think
everyone's initial instinct when seeing
the gpd3 box is to answer
a question right it's like how are you
or something like this
which is not the thing you want to do
with gpd3 because once you understand
how it works it just continues
text and so on do you have any tricks or
that you've already found out like tips
to to share what is the new way that
humans have to learn
how to interact how do you ask it a
question how do you
like because when you ask a question it
will simply continue a text as if it
were on a website right
it will not give you like its opinion
it's even hard to talk about something
like this do you have any sort of
things that you realize ah that's how i
have to do it or ah here is
your neat little trick to do something
i'll
give you a bit of a cop-out answer
because i'm actually don't consider
myself particularly
proficient in gpt3 like i've played with
it a lot but not as much as other people
read gruen for that if you want the
expert tips on how to do how to use gpd3
there's a really great essay called what
was it was like ux as
alignment or something like that as a
bottleneck an alignment or something
like that
they basically make the argument is that
so they start with this example
that two i think like two navy ships
crashed into each other
and there was a warning for that but had
the same color as the background or
something like that
and so i just no one noticed it it says
and then
it's like there's an argument to be made
that the system failed to communicate an
information to the user
who could then communicate their intent
to the machine in a way that
achieved their goals so what makes
google amazing
and the reason everyone uses google is
not because
it indexed all websites alta vista did
that that's not exciting
what did what's exciting is that google
is fundamentally a ux company
they found a way to make it easy for us
humans
to make it simple for us to communicate
what we want from the machine and get
answers that are useful to us
this is an extremely hard problem
especially with such a teeny window such
as a few words of text honestly
google is such a goddamn
miracle that it works at all like i
could just enter at google and if
it's on the first page i don't even look
if it's down the first three links
i don't even bother it doesn't exist
[Laughter]
the best place to hide a dead body is on
page two of the search results
yeah absolutely and i i i i do remember
it's
slightly being worse when i was younger
but honestly it is that good that's the
thing it just actually is that good
is i don't have to look at the second
page ever
like maybe the third link maybe the
fifth if i'm really unlucky looking for
something obscure but for the most part
i could just enter
three vaguely related words and it gives
me exactly what i want
and that is not because my words were
particularly great it's because google
is great
it's because there's so much brain power
engineering effort
went into making a google that is
aligned to me
as a human if an alien used google it
wouldn't work at all
even if it spoke our language it would
it would ask something that google does
not understand and would just
spit out garbage because it's an alien
you're contrasting google and gbt3
and google is this hierarchy of systems
i think what really made google overtake
out of vista and
is it the early 2000s is the page rank
algorithm which is a ranker
and and now they have a series of
rankers that fire in sequence depending
on how many results there are
presumably they also look at how many
people are clicking on the links they do
some kind of collaborative filtering
they do
some deep learning models they do a
whole bunch of stuff and
they also root your query and they're
looking at semantic stores and they're
looking at knowledge graphs and
they've built this incredible system for
doing information retrieval
and gpt3 is just like one black box
yeah and that's the thing gpu 3 is in
google gpt 3
is google's data box data center and now
we have to build a google on top of gpd3
that's my point gpu three is like alta
vista the data is there
but prompting is really hard and i
expect the next billion trillion dollar
you know company of this sort will be
the one to build a google on top of gb3
if
and let's be honest it's going to be
google again google already has models
internally like
i've actually heard from this is hearsay
don't you know dangerous word but i've
heard from
google people that they already have a
gpt3 model in her in-house they already
trained one
and already experimenting with it so i
expect of course they do like why is
this
does that even you know surprising of
course they do this is not surprising
and like you can even if you read the
papers which group did it it's not even
hard to guess
and so i expect that
probably google probably microsoft and
like a few other things are currently
having their like secret black ops
divisions trying to build a google on
top of these models
using clever prompting like siri type
stuff and like hard-coded rules
but then also stuff like reinforcement
learning i already said this i'm a huge
fan of
paul cristiano's work at openai they did
a great paper called learning to
summarize from human feedback where they
basically use
human feedback as reward signals to
train a model to summarize like a gbt
model to summarize text
better than humans do actually and yes
this
this is actually really fascinating
because you can with reinforcement
learning you could like
this is what google does is you can't do
supervised learning on google queries
like
there's no supervised data there you
have you have at best a reinforcement
learning center
did the human click on the first link or
not but the best you get
and i expect that in the future with
like reinforcement learning with
google type services siri type
hard-coded rules or whatever
there's going to be interface like that
i expect gpt to be integrated to siri
within the next five years
this gets into one of the other points i
wanted to make i
want to talk about the database example
from matt brockman
now the dream here and you framed this
up the other week is
software 3.0 it's prompt engineering
and yannick is making the argument quite
a lot that the only problem is that
and you've just made it's very difficult
to design these prompts
but i must admit i know i've got no
agenda here i would love it if gbt3
worked i certainly
have no interest in making it look bad
but i've tried to do prompt engineering
on gpt3
and on the database example there's a
dichotomy between
saying to gbt3 i want to build this
application and on the other hand
letting gpt3 lead you
so on matt brockman's database example
it had in bold
world is tom or something like that and
it was
made to appear as if matt brockman came
up with that prompt
but that actually was one of the things
that gpt3 led you to ask
if you put in the bit above i'm more
interested in gpt four five six and
jupiter three
and gp3 was not explicitly trained on
code it was not explicitly trading with
this goal
and i expect this i think the most
important paper this year
other than gp3 is learning to summarize
by human feedback from paul christiana's
group
i think it's probably the most important
paper to be published because it shows
a roadmap for how these problems can be
solved
like you you asked the good question how
can we
you know communicate to gpt3 what a good
program is like this is such a
abstract concept and i expect that to be
very hard but the question is how do we
communicate to humans
what a good program is how do we teach
humans at the end of the day
reinforcement learning you write a
program that works you write a program
it doesn't write a program that your
boss right yells at you you write a
program your boss doesn't yell at you
at the end of the day humans don't get
magic information we don't get
magical insight into code i've worked
with interns
i know that we don't have magical
insight into coding
and so i expect that in the near future
expect like again conor predictions for
five years in the future
maybe next year visual studio code will
have a new
intellisense add-on running on gpt which
will be a gbt
trained with reinforcement learning on
good coding style and it will like
suggest to you
you can press a shortcut enter a thing
right a quick sort here and click the
button now just
paste it and this will be a really
complicated thing in the background you
know this will be trained on like
hundreds of thousands of reinforcement
learning examples and it can be like
different models for different use cases
it's gonna be a huge
complicated microsoft scale thing in the
background but it's going to
fundamentally
work on a unsupervised knowledge base as
you're trained on all of github or
whatever
a suit a reinforcement learning on top
of that which learns how to use this
thing
and then that's how you actually extract
the information i expect that humans
need a
assistant a reinforcement learning
assistant a brain thing on top
of the gpt that helps extract the useful
information
i i think to a large degree like that is
for example what this that's
larger with the speech module in the
human shows is i get a lot of feedback
if i talk good i see people smile at me
or you know they say ah that was really
fun to talk to you or something there's
lots of feedback i get in this sort
so my model learns okay here's the
hidden state
of what conor wants to tell these people
now i have how do i say this in a way
that's fun for people or that people
will listen to me for
and that's fundamentally a reinforcement
problem
it is but then you have the problem of
evaluation
because i wanted to ask this question as
well because gbt3 is a bit
finicky in the sense that there's lots
of parameters to tweak it's not
deterministic because we do this
stochastic sampling of the model and if
you do make it deterministic it gets
stuck in loop so you want it to be
stochastic but then
from a software point of view it becomes
very challenging to deal with because
you get different results every time
another thing i notice is on this matt
brockman example
it's so tempting for us to look at the
results and we have this anthropocentric
lens
so it looks like a software application
what i did was i changed all of the
words so i changed database to be xyz
and i changed once to be just some
random letters
and i realized that it doesn't actually
matter what the words are it's just
doing
it appears to be just doing pattern
matching on the tokens
and and then i'm starting to think was
it even is it doing any natural language
understanding and is it doing any
information retrieval
or is it just pattern matching between
where i'm putting the tokens in the
prompt
to be fair powder matching is touring
complete so like
you could implement a database using
nothing but pattern matching that or a
string substitution or something like
that
so again we run into this universality
thing of what's the difference
at some point it's again it's a
polynomial difference at most
so yeah what was your take on that
database example
yeah it just seems brittle and it just
seems
like this is a thing that worked and you
might
be like it predicts the next query
as well and i'm not that surprised that
if you go by the queries that it itself
predicts that it then
gives sensible answers especially fiddle
around we
we discovered you had to fiddle around
pretty clearly with the words
like how you ask the questions and so on
and then
it's not like it's not as impressive
anymore it's it means a different thing
this data point it means it gives a
different kind of evidence
of for what it's doing and that was just
that database example
yeah i actually totally i think it's a
really good framing to saying that it's
still
impressive but it's like impressive for
a different reason or it tells us
something different
because again try to get like a high
school student to do these examples
it's actually not that easy if you tell
a high school student x
okay all right and why okay what is x
like it's actually not that
i i would ex i would predict if you try
these exact
oh this would be a great youtube video
great youtube video idea take a bunch of
gpt three prompts and give them to high
schoolers and see how good they do
i think that would be a great video i'd
watch that
i predict they do worse than gpg3 like
they would give you less useful output
not all of them i think they would
greatly outperform on certain queries
but i predict on many queries
they would perform about the same level
or worse
because like we as scientists have been
trained
rightfully so to not anthropomorphize
our machines
for good reasons and i'm going to make
the socially taboo suggestion that i
think we should have to report more of
gp3 more
i think jpd3 is much closer
in its flaws and strengths to whatever
the human algorithm is than like any
other machine we've ever built
i've already anthropomorphized all the
image models when i i made them do
rorschach tests and so on
maybe we can do the same yeah the hard
thing is to
to ask it questions that's what i find
the hard thing if it was like a
like i've experimented with facebook's
blender chatbot
which is also very good right it's more
it's way more limited and so on and what
it can do but
it's also very good and at least it has
this notion of a conversation
it has this okay you now i now you
now i and uh gpg3
does not have that so it is extremely
hard to get
to get it to do anything that you want
as you say we need like something on
top that we can give our input somehow
because i would love to ask it
questions but yeah if it were something
like
burnt that would be interesting too if
we can you know leave out
a certain passage in text and say fill
this in please
this would be very interesting too but
all you can do is say
complete please complete things and that
makes it just really hard
one of the things that i struggled with
is it's quite hard to know whether
it actually understood or answered your
question correctly
and sometimes if you just let it
continue it'll contradict itself and
just do the opposite of what it just did
before
yeah of course and again it's because an
artifact of how it's trained
how it's trained how it works also
sometimes the the sampling just throws
it off
it's imagine there's a 10 chance that
every time
you just speak a random word every time
you want to say where did you say a
completely different word
that's what it is like to be gpt is that
you know occasionally it will say
something it did not meant to say
and you're not allowed like i've seen
this this metaphor it's like gp3 is like
human who's forced to keep writing at a
very a completely constant pace and can
never go back to
erase things that's kind of what's like
because it also gets exactly the same
amount of compute for every word well
with humans we sometimes stutter we
sometimes take a second
because we have this particularly
difficult word which i think is what
happening is that we fit a token where
our confidence isn't that high so we
beam search and we try a few different
variants
and then select whichever one turns out
best and this is implementable if
someone wants to implement this in gpd3
that's doable
beam search is still a greedy search but
it's it's slightly better isn't it built
on the best first search but
we can use the analogy here of alphago
so you learn a model-free policy
and then you do this monte carlo tree
search and then somewhere in that tree
is a really good move and it's similar
to what we have here so you're saying
we're only one step towards where we
want to be
we now have this gbt3 model and we need
to do some kind of tree search which is
better than the kind of naive greedy
searches that we're doing
and somewhere in there will be the the
correct response which will seem to be
intelligent and seem to be doing
reasoning
it's probably one step i don't think
it's going to be everything because
people have done this
and as far as i can tell these um
results were usually pretty
underwhelming
it's like implementing like what i've
heard from open eye people
in personal discussions they said they
implemented beam search and gpd3 but it
just wasn't that impressive it just
actually did not make that big of a
difference
it didn't make no difference but didn't
make a very large difference
so i expect that probably it's going to
be this multi-model thing
is that we're gonna have these like
multi-modal constraints or can like what
the brain does it has constraints is
that your speech thing might be saying
one thing but the visual thing
says remember the object was red you
have to call it red but ah the word red
doesn't fit oh
scarlet that's a good word i would say
scarlet probably something like that
or completely different who knows maybe
as i said gp3
is already doing this internally it
might be that every layer
is a kind of guess a kind of beam search
or of something
probably not i know i must admit though
after speaking with wally suburb because
i've gone from your position which is
absolute hatred of go5 people and all
this knowledge graph stuff to actually
thinking
maybe that they're onto something i must
admit though i'll probably do full cycle
to be fair i'm a big fan of marvin
minsky i think marvin minsky had a lot
of great ideas they're like forgotten
and underappreciated i
like his book society of mine was the
first ai book i read
and it's still one of my favorite it's
really good i
think he was wrong that we're going to
implement ai in prologue
or whatever the but there are good
ideas there like there are good ideas
present
it's just it's not there's just other
things where it's
just doesn't work necessarily like i'm a
big fan of like type theory like haskell
and
like all these like obscure like uh you
know which is an actual programming
language i'm not
saying an uh epithet uh
of provable coding proven programs and
stuff i think it's super cool
and such that's not gonna lead to ai
is it i don't know
thanks my pleasure conor leahy thank you
very much for joining us this evening
it's always an absolute pleasure sir
absolutely thank you amazing and in this
segment of the show we talk with waleed
sabha waleed has had a huge influence on
me after i discovered his writings
online
he's a good old-fashioned ai person and
his specialism is in natural language
understanding
and as you could tell from the episode
that we did with him recently
his thesis is that natural language
processing is not the same
as natural language understanding and
after having played with gbt3 for
several hours we got his take
on what he thinks of gbt3 we've been
playing with this together now for a few
hours and
in in some ways it surprised us but
overall
what we said the other week about
natural language processing is not
understanding blah blah blah
i think that the main point that that
you're making is it still doesn't help
us with the missing text
there it's not even close if i was them
i would try to make it more of a
predictive engine for helping
people do some kind of development or
find
relevant information or it's a retrieval
engine more than anything
there's there's no even nlp
let alone nlu come on there's no
understanding
whatsoever this is just an engine that
has digested millions of sexual patterns
and it will spit out something similar
to your prompt
so the word understanding is even it
should not be on
on the same planet there is no language
capabilities whatsoever
the text matching thing is interesting
because we noticed that even if we
change things to be
gobbledygook or just letters it still
worked reasonably well it didn't seem to
matter what the word was it was just the
pattern
the other thing we noticed was that it
seems to be
dominated more by the prompt than the
corpus it was trained on
so if you give it a prompt it that seems
to overwhelmingly determine what the
output is
don't forget the prompt is the input to
the network so the prompt
is the i mean that's your that's your
test case
to the network it's okay i've seen all
the examples
the prompt is the input so it it does
all the activation the prompt is the
thing
right the prompt is the new example
and so it's and it's going to through
the network and saying
okay i'm in this space
okay i've seen this pattern and so it's
look it's a massive dictionary it's a
massive hash table of
everything it saw before but to put that
in the context of language understanding
it we're talking even apples and oranges
there is a use for it i saw glimpses of
powerful pattern recognition
man with two examples that can figure
out a pattern that's powerful but don't
sell it as something that it's not
right that's my only issue with it so i
i learned a lot by seeing it
actually could you define exactly what
you mean by
understanding and what you mean by a
pattern matching
in the most succinct way possible right
i think that's the
main question right pattern recognition
uh i i wrote something recently about
learning versus knowledge you learn how
to ride a bicycle you learn how to play
guitars but that's different from
understanding or knowledge like to and
we don't
really learn that the circumference of a
circle is 2 pi
r we are told or we discover it by
deduction
why we don't learn it because if i learn
it and you learn it we can learn it
differently
pattern recognition is a skill right and
it's a function of what i see and what i
experience which is the
ml paradigm right that's the machine
learning paradigm i saw all of these
things
now i know we say i know how to do this
but you really don't this is not
knowledge this is
pattern recognition i i saw too many of
these so
understanding is different understanding
is binary
i think i understand so are you saying
though that understanding and knowledge
are synonymous
understanding our knowledge not
synonymous but
definitely if and only if they go
together so
they but with pattern recognition
there's no understanding
when i start to recognize that this is a
cat i don't understand anything i just
i know now what a cat looks like it
there's no understanding the
understanding and pattern recognition
are two orthogonal things that
if i start to recognize
when a child recognizes that this is a
seven
they don't have any knowledge they just
know what a seven looks like
okay in in everyday
ordinary language speak we say i know
what a 7 looks like
but the word i know here is
is different from i know that
water boils at 100 degrees centigrade
because
that is a fact that i have no no
option and knowing it differently i just
yeah
right there's a if if you recognize dogs
you don't know anything
you just know what a dog looks like we
say i know but you
there's no knowledge it's so pattern
recognition
is a powerful thing it's uh a big
fraction of what we do every day
but it's different from understanding
and knowledge and in language
understanding
the choice you don't have too many
choices
it's binary there's a slightly different
way because um
keith and i were trying to wrestle with
this earlier pattern recognition to me
that seems to be like the glue
so that's transforming from one space
into another space for example we might
receive
information in gridded on a 2d planar
manifold
like a cnn does and we need to somehow
transform that into a one hot
representation or
just something just so that we can work
with it so that's the glue but then the
knowledge
i know you just said i know what it's
like to understand the seven but also
that there's some kind of an ontological
structure
and when we have this structure then we
can do reasoning
and reasoning is super useful for what
you describe as the missing information
problem because we can perform basic
deductions
i'm in the missing information domain i
saw
a bull shape on the tennis court i
assume it must be a tennis ball because
i'm on the tennis court
once we have the knowledge and we have
some information then we can do this
reasoning i think that's what you're
getting at
reasoning requires a base
to start from recognition doesn't to
reason
i need to base my reasoning on something
let's call it the ontological structure
let's call it
the axioms of how the world runs the
physical actions the
there are there are axioms in the world
we live in right
you cannot reason from nothing right
pattern recognition happens from nothing
i just recognize cats
right so the two are different pattern
recognition is
oh i stumbled upon something few times
and i
now know what that is reasoning is a
different beast
reasoning requires a base in language it
requires a certain ontological structure
that guides
how we understand few things and we take
them for granted
the missing text whatever which is the
missing knowledge that we have
that has to come in to do the
understanding
so in informal logic for example you
reason but you start with some axioms
geometrical reason starts with some
axioms of geometry
reasoning in life has axioms called
the metaphysics of the word how the word
runs is the base
you can't reason from vacuum you can't
you need
so but pattern recognition happens in
vacuum
there are objects that i see for the
first time
and and then i start to recognize them
for a child when they saw
seven they they didn't need anything
else except their sensory input
that's interesting to to bring it back
to gpt3 then so
i think what what you're saying then is
that it is
a pattern matcher it does information
retrieval but i assume you would think
of that as a
within the domain of pattern matching i
i think
look it was a it was and it still is a
great experiment
and at least it tested the hypothesis
does
more data the hypothesis that
if i get to a point where i'm making the
probability
almost certain that i've discovered all
the
possibilities and actually chomsky would
be happy
to know the result because he told them
long time ago and they misunderstood
actually his comment
that speaking of the probability of a
sentence is a meaningless notion
what he was alluding to is the infinite
nature of how many thoughts i can make
and that's how many
utterances i can make to express that
thought
and so even trillion over infinity is
zero
you're still nowhere so this was a great
experiment in testing chomsky's
hypothesis that
if you see and i guarantee you they make
gpt6
gpt 10 and they pro they process
all the text that has ever been written
by
humankind it's their word
it would still be fooled by one little
example
that a four year old understands in a in
a microsecond so
could i press you on that point though
so i understand your point you're saying
the domain of language is infinite
but it's not uniformly infinite
so if we did have a sufficient amount of
training data
would it work 80 of the time or do you
think it would just be a complete waste
of time
that's the that's trump's infinity and
i'll tell you i
it took me a long time to understand
again i'm not a chomskin but obviously
he knows
a few things about the mind and language
what he was
talking about is look you
and and people speak of domain-specific
nlu
and they can if we circumscribe the
domain
and and we constrain it and the the
thing about language or any infinite
domain and that's why game playing is
not a test for ai
alan turing was genius to consider
language
the test for ai when you get to the
infinite
right all your probabilities are
meaningless because there's no
distribution there's no if you stop
someone on the streets on the street in
san francisco
what they might say you can predict with
a meaningless probability you you don't
know what thought i'm gonna say so no
matter how many patterns
this is where they miss the crux of the
problem in language
no matter how many expressions if i put
one of the prepositions in this sentence
in a different place the entire meaning
is the thought
i'm trying to express is now completely
different
that's why they can do something and
summarization
and clustering because the topic the
general theme okay you can discover by
because it's i go back to compression
it's a compression thing
okay all this text forget the nuances of
the thoughts that are underneath this
text
what is it about it's it's sort of a
compression
that you can do in an excellent way you
can
give me the key phrases that's
compression too you can
but to understand the thought behind a
single sentence
is not a pattern recognition and all
statistical
nlu fails miserably there's no
probability here
here's the thing the thought behind
every sentence
is not ambiguous so it's a binary
decision
and that alone should tell you that
probabilities don't mean anything
look if if you take a simple sentence
average length average whatever there's
in any sentence
at least 12 possible meanings at least
if you count lexical ambiguity the fact
that
different words mean on average six
seven things
if you take the structure ambiguity
because you can parse the centers at
least in three different ways
some of them 20 but possible structural
breakups if you combine that with scope
ambiguity and you and of course you have
to multiply them
because it's the combination any average
sentence has at least 20
possible thoughts underneath it but
guess what
the actual thought that it's it is
conveying is one
otherwise we will stop each other every
time and say wait a minute what do you
mean by the previous subject we know
what we mean
so out of 40 50 possible meanings of
every sentence the decision is binary
either you understood it or you didn't
so there is no place for probability
there's no place for probably you mean
this
what do you mean probably that's what
these guys miss
language is a binary decision if you
want to do understanding
if you again if you want to do
summarization hey
you can allow three possible
interpretations and
because you're trying to get the gist of
this you're trying to do compression you
can do
understanding is uncompressing out of
the 50 meanings
of this utterance that i mean
it's a different problem that's why nlp
is a different discipline from nlu i'm
even suggesting for the community to
call nlu something else
it is not about processing language
understanding is about
uncovering the thought behind an
utterance
and that is a binary decision there is
no approximation
zero degrees of freedom this is
fascinating because i must admit since
speaking with you walid it's
it's opened up my eyes and i can't
unknow this information now
i see it everywhere because now i know
what to look for
but just to sum up a little bit then so
i i think i personally agree with you
my friend yannick and connor that they
are still attending towards the the
statistical
but there's this trend which is
unfortunate actually
to to to to redefine success
uh a colleague of uh he's a friend slash
colleague is a ucla
professor wrote a nice article in acm
that we we are claiming
a lot of successes now in ai not because
we're succeeding in ai but because we're
redefining success
so one way to to do this in language is
to say
i don't have to fully and i've heard
this imagine
rational people for all intents and
purposes say
who says we have to understand language
like we do so we want to redefine
success
just because we're so passionate about
deep learning it's funny that
no we do reasoning we i can prove it in
20 seconds
we reason actually a lot more than we
think
because we subconsciously reason even
and and formal reasoning
if then we do reason and language
understanding is
binary it doesn't it's not approximate i
can prove it again in another 20 seconds
so to
one way to solve a problem is to ignore
it sure there is this trend
who says we need to do this well if you
don't want to do language understanding
then don't but don't claim but don't
claim you don't know you
because i think some of the i've tried
to understand the thread
of of thinking here i think some of
these people
are trying to go the other way and
almost say that human intelligence
isn't what we think it is it's more
procedural
it's just a generative function and
we're not doing any reasoning either
it is procedural and i am a physicalist
and i am a material
materialist and there is a program that
can simulate the mind
eventually so i'm in that camp
definitely i don't believe in
any supernatural powers or the soul or
whatever
the mind can be formally described at
some point
all i'm saying is from data and
observation alone
we can only get what other species get
from sensory input
pattern recognition skills we have a lot
more that's all i'm saying
i'm saying our mind is not the mind
of a rat it does a lot more than pattern
recognition
and that's one way to tackle some of the
things we do
yes we do it and it's a useful
technology we do a lot of pattern
recognition
but we do reasoning we we have
knowledge we have a mind and the mind is
not just
a pattern recognition machine that
no we do reasoning actually i think we
are born with some
logical axioms like for example
a four-year-old if you ask him to put
the laptop in a briefcase and it doesn't
fit try to tell them to put it in a
smaller briefcase
they would because they know if it's
smaller if it's bigger than this and
this is smaller
they know this is if then this is
transitivity
so we are born with transitive logic if
x is bigger than y and y is bigger than
z
we are born with it because i never
taught it to my kid
they know if it didn't fit here and this
is smaller
and i say okay try that one they would
say come on
they did the transitive logic animals
cannot animals do not
we are born with a mind that does
reasoning there are
the evidence is i hope i don't have to
prove that
and that cannot you cannot get that
skill
from data that's
my view on the whole thing we have
something else
so to say i was shocked
the other day i read something a quote
for jeff hanson before he made some
comments that i said
okay there's some sanity here and then
he made the other
day a quote that he said eventually deep
learning will learn everything
don't make statements like this
don't statistical correlations
is one useful thing there's a lot
more in the mind there's ample evidence
and not everything is approximate there
are facts
that are true in spite of
us we have nothing to do with it we
simply discover them
we didn't learn that the circumference
of a circle again i go back to
that it stooped by r by experience
we didn't sense it it is a fact even if
humanity
never existed so it's not up to us or
our sensory input or observation
if humanity never existed and there was
this
vacuum in the universe the circumference
of a circle is due by r
it indeed and and and i can give a
million other examples
so we didn't learn this and we are
and and i believe we are born with a lot
of that we
are born with a lot of this basic logic
fantastic so i think we agree then that
gbt3 isn't demonstrating natural
language understanding but
the other couple of things i noticed it
was pitched as a kind of software 3.0 so
through
prompt engineering you can make it do
something akin to software
but yeah i think what a lot of people
didn't realize is that it's a stochastic
sampling method
using some kind of greedy tree search
type algorithm and you're
probabilistically sampling from gbt3 so
different results every time cumbersome
using different parameters
doesn't really seem appropriate for
software because for software it needs
to produce the same results every time
and we tried few things and actually
i was almost overly excited when we did
because it can recognize patterns so if
you give it a list and you give it the
output
as let's say arranged or sorted it can
figure out that you're trying to sort
the list over it
but apparently it's also fetching
similar examples when we changed the
name
from like we tried lengths and styles
for example so
length of a list that had five elements
it gave us five
and i was because for a long time i
worked in program transformation and
automatic programming
the the dream of generating programs
from
if you give me a couple of high level
specs i can discover the program
so i was excited for a few seconds and
then we said
and we gave it a definition remember
like an actual definition of the length
and when we applied it it gave us the
length but apparently it was using the
keyword length
it knew that length less they want the
length of a list we tried size at work
because in some programming languages
its size but then when we change the
function name to
gibberish because the function name
should be irrelevant
the specification of the function is the
semantics of the program
it then it was horrible so it's even
fetching
size and length from memory the thing
that did
impress me i i should say that we go
back to this
pattern recognition it's so powerful at
detecting
your pattern from a prompt and we tried
sometimes
we just gave two examples and it picked
up the pattern
that's impressive definitely but
if we go back to language and
understanding in a way it confirmed what
i know
and what i suspected that it's
memorizing tons of textual patterns and
then it's saying
okay your prompt looks the closest to
this because your prompt really is the
input to the network and
a certain place is activated because
that's where it saw a lot of this
that's all it's doing so it's not even
close to anything we call understanding
yeah i think it's it's unfair to use the
word understanding
when it comes to language with gpt3 but
it's a nice experiment i've come around
to your way of thinking
yeah we're too far from that language is
there are examples i can give we didn't
get to resolving scope and
that beast cannot be just from examples
if you look at what a child is doing
resolving scope resolving nfl
resolving pronouns and they answer you
as soon as they hear it if you if people
that didn't work in computational
linguistics will never appreciate this
but that's why the data driven it's hard
to explain to people that are doing
just statistical data driven inputs on
language
if you go back to some of the really
hardcore algorithms income
when you're trying to understand the
language you build a stack
and you and you and you put all the
references so that
you will go and resolve the reference
with entities that were discussed before
the the procedure is so complex
that what's her name she in one
conference
i i saw years ago she said if you work
in computational linguistics real
language understanding
for several years you might come to the
you might say you know what there might
be a god like
it's such a complex problem right
just resolving references resolving
prepositional attachments
i i had pizza with my kids you didn't
put your kids as a topping
i had pizza with pineapple was a topic
and children resolve that so
we're redefining success unfortunately
we're saying
okay it looks good it looks good but
okay but you're trying to solve a
different problem
my main issue is be be scientific about
your claims
gpt 3 is going to write
stories for us that was a headline in a
respectable
newspaper no gpt-3
will spit out stuff it saw before that's
it
but you know the fascinating thing is if
you google the stuff that gpt 3 gives
you you'll never find it it
it goes from it it comes from a variety
of sources and it
zips it together and so there is
something quite interesting about that
right but you will find it in different
places
oh in indeed you will but what's
interesting is that yeah
it is still inside the convex hull of
information that already exists but
it is so um
finely that it's almost novel yes
there is it's an achievement to know
that this goes with
this right indeed but
anyway waleed sabha thank you so much
for joining us again it's an absolute
pleasure
thanks thanks in this segment of the
show keith duggar and i
have a conversation about why do we use
machine learning
is it to do things that we can't write
code to do
and also we talk about the dichotomy
between pattern recognition
and reasoning computationally what are
the difference between the two
i hope you enjoy it you're right most of
the time with gbt3 you can just write
the same thing with code and it would be
better
but that begs the question the main
reason we use machine learning is
because you can do things that you can't
write code to do
and that is still the case for a lot of
things with gbt3
so you can do some basic sentiment
analysis or something
and it would give you results that you
could not explicitly code
is that a fair statement yeah so i
wonder why a lot of the times
we're judging gpt-3 or playing around
with examples that
are things that we can code i don't need
a neural network to
loop through items one through 100 and
print them out
or something and for building a database
for example
we do know how to code that and we do
code that people have been having
conversations about
like why it's difficult to program
things for a long time like
why is it so hard to program a computer
to describe
how to make a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
because programming because of the kind
of digital nature of it and and how
fragile it is
it forces you to think about every
single detail
every single corner case everything has
to be explicitly
laid out and when you do that in real
world scenarios that's where you start
to get into all these
little caveats and things where you
realize you need a precise
formulation you can't have some kind of
wishy gushy
wishy-washy almost gets it 98 correct
like type thing yeah like this video
yannick just made about the
the partial differential equations i
think it's really cool paper really cool
approach but like i uploaded that
screenshot of
look this is different from ground truth
like it's making all these little
errors here there's some extra vortices
over in this section right
depending on your application that could
be
everything like that could be the make
or break
situation whether or not it predicts
like some extra vortices that shouldn't
be there
right but he did say it wasn't
significantly different
to the the standard way of doing it or
simulating it
that's it the navier stokes equation
yeah but i wasn't clear on whether the
ground truth that they had in there was
simulated
or actual experimental data
got so simulated simulated right and so
in that case
it is different my point is that those
vortices that it predicted or the
different shapes
might not matter depending on your
application or they might
matter a lot if we're just trying to
print out a navier stokes
simulation to put on your wall up there
next to the other kind of like artwork
you have
it doesn't matter but if we're
simulating like heart valves or
something like that
those vortices could mean all the
difference between building up plaque
on your artery walls and not and so
that's my point is that in a lot of real
world applications
the devil's in the details and that's
why if you're a practitioner out there
trying to solve real problems
you find out that this kind of vagary
that's inherent
sometimes in machine learning just
doesn't cut it
that's right but that's quite an
interesting analogy right because
these navia stokes equations they are
they're fairly parsimonious they're
fairly understandable the alternative is
you just have this black box machine
learning model that
seems to do something vaguely similar
that is a nice analog to gpt 3
because the alternative is we can
explicitly program something using code
and its operating characteristics and
behaviors are reasonably understandable
it probably generalizes better it will
have fewer failure modes
the alternative is we use gpt 3 and we
describe a software program
there seems to be concentric circles
here because what is the software doing
is it a sorting algorithm
is it something that we could explicitly
code clearly using gbt3 doesn't seem to
be a good idea
is it something that requires some
degree of natural language understanding
or processing or information retrieval
these are things that we couldn't easily
write with code so that does make me
want to use gbt3
with the caveat that i don't understand
how it works yeah that's why
i think the the future lies in and
hybrid systems
it's using programming and things
like logic and mathematics and whatever
in the domain where they're useful and
using machine learning and neural nets
and whatnot
in the domain where they're useful and
just like we learned that
it's very difficult to solve some
problems by writing code
problems with neural networks and so we
need to have
a hybrid system i think that's what
wallet was advocating like i know
everybody
focused on him saying oh gpt can't do x
y z
but a lot of what he was talking about
was the things that
machine learning can do creating vectors
that represent
some type of meanings and words word
back uh all of that sort of thing
so i think he advocates for a hybrid
system where you have
neural networks and other machine
learned components that
on top of that or alongside that you
have a logical layer that can also do
reasoning and you can program in uh the
logic or the digital
structure and whatnot that you want in
there that's the future it's not one or
the other
it isn't it's like the capsule network
idea right like we have capsules and
whatever
capsules whatever it is uh deep neural
network
a something else a gpt three doesn't
matter
that capsule does something and then on
top of that there's higher level logic
essentially that can treat that capsule
as as the output of a variable it gets
set and then i can reason about that
that's what i'm really interested in
yeah look machine learning is great at
doing these things but we need to have
other layers that can perform logic and
in which we can
encode structure and yeah i think what
wallid has articulated beautifully
is that everything we're doing in
machine learning right now is pattern
recognition
and that is completely divorced from
understanding
this is where i think part of the
disconnect might be between
you and i and yannick and connor is
i think these terms have to be a bit
better defined like we have to decide
okay like writing down in some logic
whatever it is first order logic second
or logic
some crystal clear statement this is
what
we define as pattern recognition this is
what we define
as reasoning and here's why the two
here's why i can't map pattern
recognition to reasoning
for example i mean my simple definition
of understanding is the ability to
perform reasoning
so what is reasoning is it the ability
to produce
first order logic rules you need that to
perform reasoning but reasoning is the
ability to make simple deductions and
even inferences
over some topological information
yeah so that's first order logic right
yeah that's the tool of choice to do it
yeah
yeah and so you can program kind of a
machine
to generate to take a set of axioms
and apply the rules of first order logic
and generate
true statements like you're gonna you
can build a machine to do that
it's not difficult as to whether or not
you
arrive at the true statement that you're
looking for
i.e a proof like here's my proof for
this true statement
which is what i was looking for is that
what we mean by
reasoning uh yeah yeah it is i think the
only reason it didn't work the first
time around was
the brittleness and the amount of
knowledge that needed to be imputed
and waleed said he solved this but the
one thing we don't have with ai systems
is abstraction
and waleed said he solved the
abstraction problem by coming up with a
type hierarchy
so that eliminates the need to create an
infinite amount of knowledge so i cut so
i'm just trying to keep it in a simple
arena right now which is just defining
what is reasoning
and if reasoning is just the application
of
first order logic rules or lambda
calculus
or something like that we can build
machines to do that
obviously the semantics there it's left
whether or not
like how the semantics get defined right
if i have an axiom that says
symbol a satisfies these predicates
is that semantic knowledge it could be
depending on what those predicates are
right and so then you can build a system
that does
first order logic and it generates new
true statements from the set of
old true statements and i guess what i'm
saying is if we define that as reasoning
then what is pattern recognition and
then we can take a look at why
pattern recognition is not reasoning we
need to have a better set of agreed upon
definitions
like you and i and connor we all agree
that this is the definition
of reasoning this is the definition of
pattern recognition maybe go so far as
to say for the time being
we're going to agree that this is our
definition of intelligence
well i can can i have a go at that so i
i say pattern recognition is
transforming data from one substrate to
another
and that might mean transforming from
gridded
vision data on a planar manifold to
let's say some kind of topological
graph it could be anything it could just
be transform it to
some one hot vector or something like
that so so it's the glue
but reasoning why don't we just take a
really simple definition what lead
called the missing information problem
so you don't necessarily need to fill in
all the missing information all the time
given a structured query i want to know
i didn't see that ball
because it was occluded but i'm on a
tennis court therefore i
assume it's a tennis ball it's not a
football so i've just filled in the
missing information problem by doing
some basic reasoning
so in that case missing information
it's it's not missing it was in your
head like the fact that you're on a
tennis court so it's only missing from
some particular data set
that's not quite right it's missing in
the sense that it certainly wasn't in
the data so walid says
about the the efficiency of spoken
communication
it's not in the data and even in this um
scene that i'm in it's not there either
because it's been occluded so i have to
reason to deduce that it was there
given some separate world knowledge that
i have so i'm having to run a program
over that
over what i've seen and my world
knowledge to produce the information
yeah but see your brain was acting on an
additional data set
so it had the quote unquote v data set
but it also had some other data which is
that it was on a tennis court
at this particular time like our
reasoning is never an operation
on data that doesn't exist it's only an
operation on data
and i get that waleed was saying okay in
the corpus on which gpt3 was trained or
whatever
there's lots of that that's an
incomplete data set
there's a bunch of pertinent information
not present there
okay but what i'm saying is the
reasoning piece happens
on the combined data which is the data
that you have of the tennis ball and
also your visual perception that you're
on a
tennis court or the fact that you
arrived at the tennis court five minutes
ago and didn't leave
so you're combining more than one data
source
like having extra data is not reasoning
it's the process of taking the combined
data set
and doing something with it and so i'm
saying that doing something with it it
sounds like it's
first order logic it's like kind of
old-school expert
system that's exactly what it is yeah it
said you have a world model
which and what it would say it's some
big ontology
and you have a whole bunch of
information that you've received
from your perception maybe you've heard
some stuff maybe you've seen some stuff
and then you do some pattern recognition
you transform it into some kind of
representation
and then there's a whole bunch of
missing information and now i've i've
got all of these
logical predicates that i can run to
fill in the missing gaps
from my world model why wouldn't i don't
i wouldn't say fill in it's
it's inferring or deducing so it's
starting with it with a data set
which in a very general sense all data
can be represented as a relation
a mathematical relation and so suppose
we've got all this information that's
encoded in this relation
and then we have a sort of classic
expert system
we have a set of rules and those rules
operate
on that relation to add new you know
elements to the set of relations to add
new
items to those relations new rows if you
will like in a database term
and so it can continue operating on
those and maybe at some point it gets to
the
transitive closure of that and it just
doesn't add anything new like it's
reasoned about
everything or whatever that's a classic
definition of what reasoning is
now let's talk about pattern recognition
so i think
pattern recognition is you take that
same relation
so you take the totality of all your
data set
and you run a function on it that
asserts
something new right like this is a dog
and so it adds
a dog assertion to the data set
and so i'm wondering what the difference
between those two
things is like it seems to me it's
really just like
a number of steps type of difference
like reasoning we consider to take place
over time and it's possibly unbounded
like it may continue to process forever
and you may never get to
transit of closure it may just keep
adding new assertions over and over
again
whereas pattern recognition is a very
finite version of that it's like i'm
i take the relation and i apply
a single function in finite time and i
assert
a finite number of new assertions right
so i'm just wondering if that's the core
difference is the pattern recognition is
like
a very limited and finite form of
reasoning
or is there some other more fundamental
difference well if you really wanted to
distill it down
pattern recognition is not symbolic we
think of it as being
vector-based in deep learning it's just
to continue a continuous geometric
morphing in some space
that's what it is right i'm not saying
it's not possible to do pattern
recognition symbolically but it just
wouldn't work very well if you the
symbolic kind of thing to me is that
processing component
so i think i'm almost thinking that in
computer science like we have a very
clear distinction between
say and i hate saying this because this
gets overused but when i say it
internet like i actually mean this like
in its formal sense
which is we have a very clear
distinction between turing complete
computational systems and those that are
not turning complete
like finite state machines for example
and so it almost sounds to me like this
is the distinction we're making
is that finite state machines
are pattern recognition and turing
machines
are capable of reasoning and so
you can make an argument that for any
kind of finite
setup whatever it is image recognition
this that the other thing
with a big enough finite state machine
i can solve the problem because after
all there are no
actual turing machines at least human
beings don't make any actual turing
machines we always have
finite storage etc but the difference is
that in principle a turing machine
is potentially infinite it can sit there
running forever
you can add more storage or whatever
whereas finite state machines are
clearly just they have a finite
bound in both space and time and so is
that the distinction we're making which
is that
conor and and organic may be saying yeah
but i can build a large enough
kind of circuit and understand language
after all
human language has a finite number of
words whatever it is 300 000
english words or something and you only
use a thousand of them every day
and if i build a large enough state
machine
and sure maybe i need to include in some
other data besides just the corpus or
have people describe
more thoroughly things in the corpus i
can build this massive maybe not gpt3
but gpt9
which will have one you know trillion or
however many quadrillions of circuits
like that will understand language
whereas on the other side of the
argument
okay so then on the other side of the
argument or maybe you and i
who are saying like maybe in principle
you could do that
but maybe not like we think it requires
this unbounded
kind of turing computation and even if
you could do it for certain problems
if you looked at any type of reasonable
efficiency metrics
the sort of computation the reasoning
approach
is just going to be far more efficient
that's right but
language is infinite it might be
possible
to build such a system which works for a
lot of language
but technically it's infinite and that's
why there should be a distinction
between waleed spoke about the natural
language compiler
right the essence of what language is or
the language generating system versus
the data which is produced which is
infinite
yeah it's technically true that you can
generate an infinite number of
natural language statements or rather
you can continue generating them forever
you could write a finite state automata
and if you just let it keep producing
presumably you could write one which
would just produce an infinite corpus of
data
so i think this is getting it what we
just talked about which is that
turing machines have this potential
infinity
at their kind of ready which is that
they can continue to calculate
forever and if you leave aside the
memory angle like
that you could continue expanding the
memory or whatever
whereas every neural network that people
train is a finite state machine
it's just got it at the end after you
train it
it has some fixed number of nodes in it
maybe even before you train it you're
just training some fixed number
of nodes maybe that's not even the hyper
parameter and so they have
at the outset this finite structure and
this is why
for example contrary to what people
think rnns are not turning complete you
have to augment
rnn's with memory
and give them unbounded time so at that
point you're really just
the rnn is just the circuitry of the
turing machine it's just the thing that
sort of does the computing but it's
operating
on some unbounded memory for an
unbounded
amount of time and so i think what we're
getting at is that
the essence of reasoning is that it's an
unbounded
computation whereas pattern recognition
maybe is bounded computation
that's a very interesting hypothesis i
think if we can
nail this down a bit in a conversation
with them do we agree with that that
that's a reasonable distinction to make
bounded versus unbounded
potentially infinite versus finite
whatever if we can get down to some
agreement on just
what we're talking about here like what
is pattern recognition
and how is it different otherwise we're
never going to get past the well it's
pattern recognition well no it's not
yeah it is no it isn't
we've got to have some way of answering
this question
and then i think from there then we can
get to
now we have this set of problems that
are potentially solvable with pattern
recognition
the set of problems that are solvable
with
unbounded computation i.e turing
machines okay
is there an overlap are those
computational classes equivalent
maybe not and then we can get to the
more interesting question of now what is
intelligence
and i think we're along the right lines
of things i think
chalet has some parts of it others have
other parts of it
but we really haven't arrived at a nice
very solid definition of it
and then once we have that and again
these are definitional issues
it's not like we're exploring and trying
to find definitions that work well
in practice definitions by themselves
don't state anything
fundamental about the universe they're
just how we divide up
the domain of discourse but at least
then we can start to communicate and
explore
interesting issues in the final segment
of the show
this is super exciting when i got access
to gbt3 we jumped on a call together we
had waleed we had keith we had yannick
and we were just like giggly school
children in a candy shop
we ran through a whole bunch of
different examples
and you can see us in real time
experimenting thinking
reacting i hope this experience will be
interesting for you because you can
relive it vicariously and you can decide
for yourselves at home
whether you think gbt3 lives up to the
hype or not
there's this guy called guern who
actually gave quite a few examples
of this so we can take one of his
examples so
here's a typical conversation here
please write me a sonnet
now the thing is this is prompt
engineering so if you condition the
input
then that will determine what comes on
the output on gwen's example
it did actually know what these numbers
were when you added them together so we
could
paste that in so it's given us that
answer
let's see what the actual answer should
be so 34 000.
that's wrong so it should be 105 721
oh even the addition was wrong yeah now
there is this thing that apparently
because of the byte pair encoding
it's really bad if you don't put spaces
in so supposedly
that would be better so we could reset
and start that again
so that's not giving us anything we can
try again
you can see the pattern here we're just
going to keep trying again and again
until it does something we like
mary enjoyed the sandwich
what did she enjoy about the sandwich it
should be eating
if i say mary enjoyed the sandwich we
all know she enjoyed eating ah she
enjoyed the taste
she ate every single day she enjoyed the
taste
she liked chocolates yeah mary enjoyed
the movie enjoy the movie yeah it should
be
what did she enjoy about the movie mary
enjoyed
a cigarette it should be she enjoyed
smoking the cigarette
it's basically it's what i suspected
it's
tons of gawkers and it's spitting out
stuff that
matches with some patterns that they've
that they've seen what i wanted to see
here
is an office in every european capital
is many it's not
an office yeah how about even just a
simpler thing like
the bbc has five offices in germany how
many does it have in europe
something like that yeah that's a good
one
should at least have five it should at
least have five if if europe is in any
way related to
germany the prompt is in us in a way
like constraining the search right yeah
answer germany
aren't so many they've got tons of
possibilities the prompt can strain it
in a way
this is an example of how you could
potentially build software with gpt
through
using important engineering i just i saw
a discussion of it but
yeah okay so the database begins knowing
nothing the database knows everything
that's added to it does not know
anything else when asked a question
if the answer's been added to the
database says the answer when asked a
question if the answer has not been
added so it does not know
does the database know what is two plus
two the database doesn't know so this is
all
this is all the prompt and what we're
doing is we're conditioning it so now
if we reset and paste all of this stuff
in so
tom is 20 years old has been added to
the database nothing else about thomas
added to the database so it should say
the database does not know now you see
what's happening here gwen
on this website he's given an example of
gpt3 seemingly
performing miracles so if we did that
now the result would be the same every
time that's that's because people are
choosing the best result from the six
that it gives
it doesn't say anything that it's better
when it's random
you know it's that's seems stupid it's
just yeah
it's giving nine different answers and
then people can look at this we can
fixate on the one that they like and say
wow it's better
and then they can ignore the other eight
that are terrible yeah so this
intelligence is actually a story of
human selection using their intelligence
at least in part
yeah yeah largely because as you say
it's boiled it down to a search problem
and humans are effectively doing the
searching
it is it is it's constrained it's
constraining the search a little bit
maybe but even then what he would have
done
because we've said i want to have 100
words and then what he would have done
is essentially copy all of this
take just the part of the answer that we
think we want
and then ask another question so you see
what we're doing is we're interactively
chopping the response and making a new
request
because my question was they did all of
the glue tasks on gpt3
like the pronoun disambiguation the
winograd schemers how did they evaluate
even the the addition and the
multiplication how did they evaluate
whether or not gbt3 got the right answer
but my issue is actually i don't see
anything intelligent coming out look the
conditioning is just pruning the search
and actually constraining
yeah oh i i have no doubt it doesn't
understand semantics but i was
trying to see if which was the challenge
put
forward by a few people that privately
they were saying
what they're trying to prove is that
statistics
at a large scale can approximate
cervantes
so my issue is i'm convinced that
doesn't do semantics they actually admit
we don't do any understanding
but can statistics at a large scale
approximate semantics you know what i'm
saying it's
that's not evidence of that no that's
what i'm
trying to investigate so you see i'm
giving you some examples
i turn the temperature up a little bit
just to get a bit of creativity
and you would agree keith i'm sure that
as soon as it's non-deterministic it
becomes almost
impossible to use this in a software
context it becomes
far more difficult to scientifically
evaluate this thing
if it's not repeatable i'm getting the
feeling that
those that want gpt3 to sound good are
testing it
with good intentions and those that want
it to fail are testing it to make it
fail and both will work
you can always give it stuff that will
look good and you can always give it
stuff that is but i definitely language
wise
where i was i i have no i'd like to see
something that will make me go
wow looks like i did a kind of
completion on that because the numbers
are monotonically increasing
maybe if it was two and one oh that that
would be a good test to give it a
pattern and say can you complete this
like one three five maybe let's try that
actually miranda can do that haskell can
do that
three five ah one more if we have to be
prompt engineers maybe we have to do
complete this pattern colon and then dot
or question mark or something that's
more what you'll find
oh cool okay it got that right starting
from nine now
right yeah it's complete it's completing
yeah oh this is good
we see something that looks like an
intelligent conversation
and it's been hidden from us that
there's been a lot of cherry picking
going on here
it should say the database does not know
no the first
queue line that was there does the
database know
yeah so just to explain this because
this is in bold this means that
all of this was the prompt oh okay i
assume because this bit is not bold this
means from this point it was an
interaction right
yeah so on the deterministic with the
temperature zero
now it says this but what's interesting
here is
whoever used this as part of the
conversation presumably snipped from
this point on
sure okay let's roll with it so then we
say i
answer we copied this in and then we go
back to
the example on the gwen website how does
the database respond when tom's eight
now this really weird that he said when
tom's age i wonder whether that was
deliberate but let's see what happened
the database says tom is 20 years old so
far so good
yeah so we're able to repeat his
database example with
temperature zero temperature zero with
the quote unquote deterministic
gpt three if you will yeah you didn't
put the next question
in that's interesting stop stop just
read the conversation
that's a more interesting part gpt3 is
like continuing to ask itself
questions yeah and funnily enough so
this is just being completed from
something on the internet isn't it this
just in
this just now completes yeah when you
say
age and then address phone number
email highly correlated so they're in
the neighborhood
but i think that the question though is
this basically just something on the
internet
it's gotta be come on if you ask for the
age you
are more likely to ask also for the
phone number and i'm guessing that's
what's happening
it's in the neighborhood the thing is if
you told it
tom is 20 years old can you ask it if
he's older than
something we can do that all right but
we were able to reproduce
database result by setting the
temperature to zero
and the top p to one correct yeah
database does not know
is tom a man a human a living thing a
person a boy
you have to enter to the database what
it means to be a teenager
interesting database only knows what is
added to it
but actually yannick it's interesting
the answers show
that it did relate teenager to
person human it's wrong but at least it
says yes
yeah should we say why it's tomorrow if
it says no
that'd be interesting then it's easy to
fix just negate everything you've done
okay yeah but but it does
at least before it accorded to the rule
that the database does not know
because you've never instructed it to
know what a teenager is and now
at least it incorporates that being a
teenager
and as you can see from the next
question
it also incorporates being a person
right because you put some information
about
being a person between the ages of 13
and 25.
did we ever say tom was a person yeah in
a teenager indirectly you said teenagers
a person that
tom is a person who is 20 years old is
added to the database
two lines above we see that no no just
towards the end
no tom is 20 years old that line needs
to say
tom is a person who is 20 years old no
but before we change anything
the fact is if we're assuming the
database is obeying the closed world
assumption
right it doesn't know that tom is a
person
no a person yeah that's why we add to it
i know but it's incorrectly claiming
that it knows
as a person when it doesn't know that
that's true so we can't have it both
ways like either
it's following closed world assumption
or it's not of course we know it's not
following any of those things
that's what i was going to say i don't
think any of that is happening it's the
thomas a person no it's just
it's interpolating from above right the
trophy doesn't fit in the suitcase
because it was uh small what does it
refer to and the answer is so now you
have to give it a question
right yeah so now give me something
similar the trophy
did fit in the suitcase because it was
small what does it what should be the
truth yeah this is obvious it should get
yeah the trophy throughout that's good
what is the stuff below there
these are just another hundred words
that it's generated because i've set out
for size 100.
right trophy did fit in the suitcase
because it was small what does it refer
to the suitcase
so if he did fit in this who gives us
the trophy yeah the trophy is small but
the bigfoot the answer is correct
no but then it gives the it's giving by
the opposite answers
that's what i'm saying that's what it
continues with because what it does is
it just detects this repeating pattern
and it continues the repeating pattern
yeah swap out the first one for an
entirely different wienergrad scheme
right but same same semantics oh okay
that's a good one the laptop did not fit
in the bag
did not fit too big the laptop
that's a good test all right can you can
you just take away the
answer colon from the prompt yeah
yeah but then it's just cycling again
just change trophy
just change the because we're we're
asking the same pattern exactly
did not fit yeah now it should be the
suitcase if there's any
did not fit because it was too small now
it should be the suitcase
because otherwise it's spitting the same
pattern the first note yeah
same thing now it should be the suitcase
but
obviously there's no understanding it's
but it's yeah
it hits sometimes yeah yeah it was it
found a pattern and it was spitting the
first noun
what if you only asked the quest the the
latter question
like the second question okay apparently
without conditioning it just
goes all over the place yeah so what's
going on with the conditioning
prompt engineering you just you make it
feel like it's in a certain context
right all you ask is what's the most
probable thing you would encounter on
the internet
when you see a context like this right
so it's
it's constraining the search right
really yeah
like this one for example whatever it is
i feel sorry for the future
gpt prompt engineers because
time they're gonna they're gonna become
good prompt engineers and then
gpt plus one is gonna come out and none
of their tricks are gonna work anymore
yeah they're gonna have to go back and
study a second book on how to do prompt
engineering
because it's just a mess right i can see
the books coming out already
this is quite impressive though isn't it
so the letters in jogging are
j o g ing and scramble they are g o j g
ing what are the letters in squatting
and what are they scrambled and it's
done it with one of the letters missing
no don't get me wrong many people are
going to make tons and tons of money off
this
this career path like far in excess of
the value that they contribute to
society
like bitcoin can we try reverse instead
of scrambling
like a straight reverse i think i saw
one try uh tried that and it worked but
yeah nick you could be the world's first
prompt engineer you know that
hey tim is doing quite well you wanna
you wanna
join my online university oh it's not
done it
look it's just giving me the same result
as last time i think
so obviously it had nothing to do with
scrambling it just memorized something
it's always so memorized oh dear
it's just starting to make us realize
that these are just cherry-picked
examples that are just demonstrating
something that's memorized on the
internet hasn't actually learned to do
anything
it makes sense replace the words letters
jogging and reversed with completely
made up words
completely made that word it must be
like as nice sounding
sound but without meaning yep
no that's fine jogging there is fine and
then okay
squatting we need a different thing for
squatting oh
and then we need actually squatting can
stay because we need those letters right
yeah but then letters the word letters
replace that and also reversed
call it limbled limbo
reversed on the top as well but there's
that
right but that's not a fair test
we are testing what oh my god
it's complete memory yeah it's not too
bad
it's better than before the green and
squirting or squirting
and limbaled they are squatting i'm
pretty sure like it just detected the
pattern of these kind of of these
letters of the uppercase single letters
and
it recognized that it's the same letter
somehow again and it just
pulls that through maybe replace
poggy with jogging again and and and
we'll see what happens
yeah now it now it interpolates the
jogging
with the squatting i'm pretty sure all
of these words around
the stuff have very little to do with
the answer you're actually getting right
what seems to be more important is like
the grammar pattern
that you input right it's like a
template yeah
yeah exactly he did an interesting one
as well called a pdf
clean up did you see that no so pdf
cleaning
he says he wastes an infuriating amount
of time cleaning up abstracts or quotes
extracted from pdfs
so here's some examples so there are
some hyphenated words
to clean text yeah
so reformat that to this so here it's
taking out the carriage returns
so that's cool isn't it i think this is
one that he did himself
i don't see any difference in the final
bold text and the output text
isn't these these hyphens that's it no
that's it
measured yeah but just some of them are
quite clever though so you see this one
it actually but those are gpt didn't do
those
they should be quite impressive yeah
that would be really cool
wow that's pretty impressive that's
impressive but it might have something
to do if this is quite a common thing
so if i use words that are not appearing
on the internet very often but
this is the first impressive thing i'm
really impressed i saw
i'm not impressed yeah neither am i
honestly i'm not impressed
why not no word splitting is fairly
challenging
it just puts spaces between but hey
it figured out where the words are i can
do that with a dictionary
yeah but you are teaching it a computer
program
through examples clean up and then
whatever text that is and and
and it'll maybe give you the same thing
oh you're saying all the above didn't
mean anything
yeah that's right i'm exactly okay oh
boy
okay that would be a good test
no oh just put the word
so it did use the above as a
no it used it as a template yeah
and it was mostly this part tim is the
person from the united kingdom
oh it didn't do it no it needed more
examples
so there was another example there okay
so there are actually just two
right so let's put these now the first
one is about
new lines were removed correct yeah
there are two for spacing only two
but i think it's the first sentence
there so you need that little
clean reformat and then reformat because
right now it doesn't know what reformat
is like
actually just go test it without the
word reformat
just put your funky word in there just
that yeah
okay and then you can try the whole to
clean just to define what reformat means
so yeah you just have to define the
thing anyway
however it's triggering it to do like
splitting up words
in the english language i think it
receives a lot of information
about that and it's basic training but
the interesting thing is
were the examples that trigger if they
were then it's impressive right
yeah if if the two above the examples
were the
pattern that followed then it's
impressive in my mind so let's give it a
little bit more instruction so that's
one which is relevant
well what else is missing because the
above examples are irrelevant right
do you have a trailing space there maybe
get rid of that
this is prompt engineering 101 okay
no trailing space don't leave a trailing
space
yeah go back to the deep learning design
it could be
that's a common phrase why this is not
that would be really curious
same thing with the
this is uh deep learning whatever this
is a deep learning article i think yeah
change it to
what's in a name yeah something common
it
then it really is it was that wasn't it
this is a deep learning article
something like that yeah yeah strange
and let's go back to where we were then
take the entire thing
now we do it and it works this is a deep
learning article yeah so what i was
going to suggest to you before
is when you were trying to do it you had
a space
after a clean reformat pdf text colon
you had a space up there so
i think it's like super sensitive to
that kind of thing
so you didn't it didn't define what the
clean
reformat is either space wave up here
after that colon no go up the first
column
you had a an empty line rather like that
and i think that broke it so
it should be like that now yeah okay
temperature not
but the examples yannick tried are cool
that was impressive i told you he's
going to be the first prompt engineer
so it knows if there are words then they
are
broken by space so you can break them
but with a pattern like you can break
them by
one character and the rest one character
and the rest
just to see if it learns a pattern but i
ah that's because the i
is an actual word just put
where it's not a one-letter word like
you are good they are good yeah
still that was impressive by the way i
didn't even
i i i didn't even expect that that's how
[Laughter]
yeah you have to prompt engineer
why don't we do the spaces thing though
that's what we're supposed to do anyway
right and so we could make that an
asterisk
that goes to oh wow
i would if i were gpt3 i'd just be like
you
come on yeah yeah
look at that what the hell nice
nice no
yes no way yes way what is it
what is the most stupid thing you can
think of
okay see this is what i'm interested in
is in
i would like to see the training
examples that lead to this
what do we have oranges what about
colon or something
on the second letter of every word so i
want it to
get rid of all of the spaces but put a
tilde in on the second
character of each word you are
good like that okay
and it's done something so not quite
it started putting the tilde between the
words from the third word onwards
so it's just starting putting that it
started putting the tildes between the
words
but what we can do is space these out to
get around the bpe thing
it picks up patterns but it's pretty
wild all you have to
although you have to be fair these are
not enough examples our food and then
you have to
put in is is banana food bmw
and volkswagen or something like this no
that would be impressive
cars that's good no that's impressive
because it found a pattern again
types of food types of cards so it's
good
that's a good pattern to me it's
impressive because i didn't expect that
to be honest yeah
that's quite impressive other than cars
just to make sure that it's generalizing
on all types of things
canary and blue jay are they should be
birds
but you oh oh i i wanted that to be the
question anyway that's fine
but you have like extra spaces but still
our car is nice
now you're giving it even more
information you should get it but i
wanted the
uh right it's insane
with embeddings alone this can happen
right yeah so you have
yeah the similarity here but they got
birds specifically the generic type
that's impressive
yeah so with patterns i can say it's
pretty good very good language
competency is another issue
but indeed but this is impressive this
is not
simple stuff this is memorization it
will find this somewhere and
spit it out not quite
okay at least that's what i think is
happening but
i uh you see there well at some point it
has memorized it
but i i could change this to be anything
so i could have
tim in the end of that and it would
still presumably work
so it's a combination of memorization
and interpolation between what i've
given it
just list the words let's make it easy
on it just to see it
okay and then what is a dot append
it's pretty impressive what it can do on
the programming stuff
ah now that would be retrievable by the
way
it might have right that would be raw
retrieval
but you have to write it like it was in
some coding
tutorial the algorithm for sorting in
python is
oh wait a minute that's that's
impressive
for other reasons yeah it's better than
half of our students
[Laughter]
that is really cool basically it's
saying what sorting is
a function for sorting a list in python
is sorted right yeah yeah that's a bit
m function that's not the algorithm but
i think it's quite
powerful in picking up patterns and
generalizing
yeah let's try grabbing some code
you know for example no it can it can be
anything but i'm assuming it will
complete this and finish the algorithm
for me would it give me the output when
i say test it
count it doesn't have to be python just
because i want to make it small
count square brackets space square
brackets
equals zero open e s
equals one plus count e s so basically
we're saying
the count of the number of elements in
an empty list is zero
the number if it has at least one object
followed by the rest
e will match the first object in the
list
old school that's that's haskell and
miranda what
trick that's cool it it actually traced
it so it knows uh
functional programming that's cool but
is that because
there is just something similar on the
internet there's no way
it three was you never know ah
you know what the word count is a
trigger so it knows this is the length
function
so it counts them although the function
name should not be relevant
g or yeah ccc okay if it does that's
impressive
okay so the word count was the minute i
get really excited
it tells me hold it man the problem with
deep learning is it's uh
shortcut city yeah but still i'm
impressed there were a few things that
okay change the ccc to length it should
also know the
keyword length yeah that was
disappointing
and that's given me a seven the way it
gave you the right result
which means the function definition is
irrelevant it's not the right group
it's longer than seven right it's also
uh it's about fourteen or fifteen
yeah wow okay so it knew that it's the
number of elements in the list and it
didn't count
all the talk about programming is
obviously memorizing
well-known functions can we conclude
that because people say
you can use it to program no i mean you
can you can it knows all the common
functions and it knows how to
find a pattern in the input output but
on well-known algorithms you cannot use
it to do
programming that's not true yeah the
same i think
but okay so it it knows all the common
functions and all the common
built-in functions but
i can definitely say it's very
impressive and picking up a pattern
from a few examples because the ones we
tried
can't be anywhere especially the
generalizing the type
the birds and the that was quite
impressive
can you search for a dialogue between
passive aggressive people
and just continue it the the the one two
three four
five and
okay just like the the but the bold not
just the bold ones
oh okay okay and then try to have a
conversation with it i don't see why
you're making such a big deal out of
this i'm just trying to help
look it up look it up nice this is not
is this did it continue the same pattern
yeah
i don't see why you're making such a big
deal out of this oh you think
it doesn't seem to be coming up but that
is quite plausible
when a passive aggressive person is
forced to comply with a request but
feels the request is unreasonable
or over demanding he or she may respond
with a phrase like this that's brilliant
that see we can like create new
diagnostic criteria for stuff
uh you can't find this anywhere on the
internet
yeah but click on the first thing click
on the
just the first thing the problem is some
of these data set comes from google
books right
a lot is from google which you can't
search through
you can yeah but doesn't it only search
through like parts of the google books
no judges for all of them there is a
books thing here yeah
you're making a big deal out of nothing
yeah breaking passive aggressive cycles
so but you were saying that we should
just do
no this is the headings yeah i mean you
can do the headings
it's also it would also be fun put 11
like
below the prompt going out now of course
i can stay a little longer
i know how to do it okay it's my fault
you'll learn i guess i could help
i thought you'd never ask
where are these coming from now this is
actually i guess
it's cooking time this most passive
aggressive scent
cooking time um
12 is fine 12 is fine oh my gosh
that's very passive aggressive you just
keep repeating those two sentences
no question mark that doesn't matter
it's there's no pattern there right yeah
there's anxiety so it just continues the
the text from above there's no pattern
no repeating pattern
the depression stuff teen depression and
then
symptoms of being at hogwarts yeah sure
why not
did you take this stuff off oh they go
feeling of being a misfit in a muggle
world a wizarding world
it's not bad actually
[Laughter]
yeah okay oh the feeling of being a
youtube content creator
that is a symptom of being a youtube
content creator
indeed hasn't seen this pattern which
yeah it's almost as if it has a bass
line right
yeah and then if if there's something it
can grab at it will
fan it out then let's try something like
i have
so i have two red shirts how many shirts
do i have
this is easy but i want to see if this
it doesn't do
anything now it it simply
takes the digit and and
copies it you put like some sort of
space at the end
if you have a space it's uh generally
bad
but it did the right thing you know oh
yeah yeah that is important
how many red things do i have you could
just probably do lovely blue two
answer two blee blah blah three answer
three
i think it's the pattern that it picked
up is if you have a two in the question
the answer is to regardless of the words
i think
that's why i want to construct something
where the pattern is some higher level
pattern
right right not on the linguistic level
where you do some sort of the same
reasoning i have more than
yeah interesting that's a reasonable
inference
because yeah you definitely have books
so you have one
yeah because you said i have less than
if you had zero you wouldn't say i have
less than
yeah i but i don't think it went that
far but
not that bad yeah i mean if you add zero
you don't say i have less than
if you say i don't have books so the
only valid answer is actually one
whether it got it this way or not i have
no idea but
it definitely is the right answer less
than three
i have less than three red books now it
says that's an ambiguous question
hey that's impressive what's happening
it's only computing less than three
regardless of what else you have
yeah i'm pretty much certain that's
what's up because you can say how many
green things i have
same thing it should say i don't know
zero or whatever that's wrong
your suggestion was how many green
things uh even if you say i have two red
books
and it's gonna say two getting it from
the one above let's say
now less than i have instead of i have a
few red books
just say less than three so green and
then less than three
and now it should answer two right
two so there's a pattern somewhere
so it's working out a pattern regardless
of the meaning of the words or the
language or
yeah okay you could probably yes you
could probably just go blah blah blah
and then yeah green or whatever just you
know they'll give the same answers i'm
pretty
although the words might be
statistically relevant somehow but yeah
okay but definitely it's not doing any
language
no who would go further than you because
you know wally you said that
natural language processing is not
natural language understanding i think
this is not even natural language
processing i think it's
some level of pattern matching even
almost
at the character level good point that's
not even doing
nlp really you can write few few lines
of code and spacey and do
all of this stuff yeah you could quite
literally as janet was saying
yeah and no wonder it's good on the
pattern recognition and extrapolation
stuff so
i don't know why they're selling it as a
language thing they could
play more on the other dangerous because
the the top two are
very similar but still it recognized
that you want the digit and it
recognized the digit three in the
sentence
it no longer says less than three right
no
but the less than at least had some
effect yeah yeah yeah
that's what i meant somehow the words
come into play but
yeah there is oh boy
ah two yeah put the digit two
in the top sentence and the digit one in
the middle sentence and then
it's gonna say three again the pattern
will be clear yeah
oh oh nice okay
so something else is happening
statistically but
well definitely there's no there's not
nothing uh called language at all
i don't think so it's not even text
processing look at what it continues
it continues with the only real
sentence that's interesting because
that's the most likely given the context
it's just the most likely
thing right yeah yeah the other two
should have
not been statistically significant at
all so
just threw them away
now back translate this oh my gosh you
know what
maybe give it the only the binary
sequence
wouldn't that be great
[Laughter]
try without the impressive right what if
you just put spaces in the queries
yeah i mean it's yeah i guess just
completing
probably want to write some script that
generates these examples or something
now the words don't mean anything all of
a sudden yeah
yeah there's no understanding whatsoever
but there's uh there's pattern
recognition at a very impressive
level what's interesting you can test it
to make it look good and you can test it
to make it not look good it depends what
you
what your motives are i've seen people
say wow this is
right it's not clear at all to the
layman
how much massaging is required how many
parameters there are what gpt3 actually
does
it's just an autoregressive language
model just spurting out
tokens and i don't think people
appreciate the level
of cherry picking that's happened in
these examples
and it's super unclear how it's been
evaluated for example when it did the
glue challenges
they reported figures that were quite
high actually
how do you know if it succeeded on a
pronoun disambiguation
look the glue and all these squad
benchmarks i don't believe all the
numbers that
they've been publishing near 98 since 10
years ago
i i don't even look at them now i i
i think yeah you're right it should be
reported on what it is what it does how
to test it it's
all of this is not trivial because you
can easily conclude things that are not
true at all
it seems to show the traps of our own
understanding when i saw the database
example i was blown away by that
and no one has access to gbt3 to try
this out and people don't really
appreciate
that this is just one example and in
that particular case
with a bit of experimentation we
realized that it was just learning some
pattern
it looked like we'd created a database
application
but actually it was just learning some
pattern on the internet appearances can
be deceiving we have to be really
careful
that's dangerous to science forget
opinion or points of view and what's
cool and what's hot and what's trending
there's a generation of engineers that
for them ai
is pytorch tensorflow and bird
that's dangerous man what if they have
to pivot
actually i have a friend who works at a
big tech giant
and he he told me we're stuck but the
problem is if you want to do some
semantics
we don't have anybody that knows
anything i think you know what i think
we are too old honestly right now
we need the creativity of a a kurt
cobain
to come up with smart things to put into
this prompt field and we
like the three of us are too old and two
sat
into the field and we think too narrowly
to even grasp the possibilities
of this that's what i think that might
be a possibility
and yeah i'm very much sticking to my
original take on gpt-3 but
at the same time i think we haven't even
scratched the surface
and the proof is we tried a few things
that really impressed because
we just tried this combination i agree
but
what leads articulation of the missing
text problem i think is a damning
indictment to gbt3 because now that i
know that i can't unknow it
because it's so glaring to me now that
is what
it can't do it will never discover what
was not said there's
that requires deep reasoning beyond what
i saw there's ambiguity everywhere right
no i i cannot see it i believe the
theoretical proof about compression and
i i cannot believe this no matter how
much you scale it
will uncover missing text no matter what
trick it does
because you don't have to do it the way
i like it to be done i like we agreed
the other time
as long as it functions as if it knows
the missing text but i cannot see that
no way
there's something outside the text from
the text
itself you will not discover that
missing stuff
and we humans have no problem with it
because we obviously
come with some basic common sense stuff
even physical
common sense stuff what falls what for
what what
flies on its own and what so we come
with a
so that stuff is missing and it's not in
the text
i i cannot see it but but we could
caveat that because yannick did a video
about
learning a knowledge graph from data and
there are some intermediate steps so you
can either learn it
tab a rossa or you could seed it but the
point is though that
if there is some kind of ontology or
knowledge graph and we could reason over
it
using some code that just implies that
we need to have a two system approach
even if you read all the
by the way the trick about i used to do
it with junior
students in computer science i used to
draw a weird symbol on the whiteboard
and say initially
look at the reaction i say i claim that
all the knowledge and the word is in
this symbol
who agrees with me initially of course
they all say what
all the knowledge in the word is in that
symbol
and as i walk them through interestingly
half of them flipped
so i said wait a minute why are you
surprised
can't i digitize everything the human
mind ever created
open your laptop you have music
paintings you have
writings everything that human mind ever
created can be digitized
all of a sudden now i have few smart
students on my side
that they immediately thought of a
binary sequence
now i have knowledge and numbers so i
said it's a huge binary sequence
definitely very huge but in the end any
binary sequence is a number
it's alif it's a huge number
it's so big that i wrote it like the
symbol
now who thinks i can put all the
knowledge in the word in this symbol
almost 80 said actually now it might it
makes sense
so yes you can put all the data
but you didn't put knowledge because
otherwise we already have
all the data in our machine the problem
is the uncompressing
okay i encoded all the knowledge in the
world
now let's decode it we decode it because
we have something else outside
that was fun i'm not a converted gt3
fanatic but i was actually impressed i
was actually impressed by few things
anyway i really hope you've enjoyed the
show today we've had so much fun making
it this has been an epic
production remember to like comment
and subscribe we love reading your
comments and we'll see you back
for an even better episode if you
thought that was possible
next week peace out